je fais un truc qui va pas je je vais
fleurir mes registres alors non je
plaisante évidemment je peux changer de
titre
est-ce que je change tous les titres
français demi-finale de la Ligue
alors je vois ce que je fais on vit dans
on aime ça ou pas
et là le problème c'est que les event a
été programmé
je fais ça
et oui
est-ce que ça a marché ou pas
je vais aller voir
et salut Arnaud bienvenue à toi quels
sont vos pour vous les trois meilleures
questions qu'il faut se poser pour les
moins de 1500 et l'eau il y a beaucoup
de débats à ce sujet en école
tu lui réponds ou tu veux que je
j'ai répondu en premier à l'autre mais
je peux moi je peux en dire un qui me
vient tout de suite
à moi de 1500 et l'eau les premières
questions c'est qu'est-ce que veut faire
mon adversaire pourquoi il joue ça et
son idée est-ce que j'ai envie qu'il le
est-ce que on fait pas confiance à son
anniversaire jamais
de la prophylaxie voilà on fait on fait
pas forcément confiance mais on
réfléchit à ce qu'il veut faire et on se
dit est-ce que j'ai envie qu'il le fasse
ou pas ou est-ce que j'ai envie de l'en
empêcher exactement
première question importante
vas-y pour la deuxième bah je pense que
je suis entièrement d'accord avec toi
dans tout ça déjà avant toute chose il
faut regarder ce que fait l'adversaire
quand vous jouez à sec ou pas tout seul
vous jouez vous jouez à un contre un
donc vous vous voulez gagner et après ça
vous pouvez aussi gagner en fait si vous
voulez gagner il faut vraiment essayer
de comprendre déjà ce que veut faire
l'adversaire avant même de savoir que
vous voulez faire vous-même et donc se
poser plein de questions du style
pourquoi il fait ça qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire qu'est-ce qu'il menace qu'est-ce
qu'il m'attaque et en fonction mais on
voit c'est déjà ce qu'on va faire donc
vous ne pouvez pas commencer à avoir un
plan si vous ne vous arrivez pas à
trouver le plan de l'adversaire ça c'est
c'est primordial et donc ça pour moi
c'est c'est le grand numéro 1 la
question de de pourquoi il fait ça
et de et de est-ce que je peux est-ce
que je peux je peux l'empêcher est-ce
que je peux comment je peux réagir tu
vois c'est tout le principe de la
prophylaxia attends je vais vous mettre
alors tu sais que ça a marché Express
donc on fait des
je vais me lancer des fleurs sinon qui
va le faire ça a marché le nouveau le
show est parti sur Youtube donc allez-y
sur Youtube abonnez-vous à la chaîne
mettez un petit pouce bleu n'hésitez pas
pour nous suivre même sur tweet allez-y
suivez-nous comme ça vous ratez rien des
chauds et vous pouvez tout voir c'est
bon ça fonctionne on nous dit sur ça
voilà et ça a commencé alors après les
ouais d'autres conseils effectivement
ça je crois que c'est le c'est le plus
important
parce que là on voit vraiment
je regarde dans mon programme
j'en ai j'en ai deux caméras
c'est la partie marche pas bon
on va pas bien le petit loup
jouer sur tablette notre ami
[Musique]
on va la voir un petit peu après
donc ça c'est ça c'est une ligne de Nick
qui commence à être un peu connu
maintenant la fameuse la fameuse
comment ça s'appelle time manov avec G4
donc elle a une grosse partie de grande
des deux sur Magnus 47 là-dessus
exactement avec un c'était quoi la ligne
il y avait eu
comment ça s'était passé un sacrifice de
pièces
Wimbledon donc c'est quoi ton c'était
quoi tes trois conseils du coup le
deuxième alors le deuxième je l'ai pas
encore donné
[Musique]
chaque prise menace alors on prenait
tous les déchets quand on fait chèque on
force l'adversaire à jouer le coup qu'on
veut une prise mais quand je prends une
pièce bah a priori si large pas mais
j'ai gagné comme du matériel donc donc
voilà enfin je viens de me je me fais on
me parle là je crois que
et troisième c'est c'est les menaces
donc quand on fait une menace quoi que
ce soit par exemple juste pour pour bien
montrer si la plage avait joué deux
menace donc
ça c'est la partie des menaces donc
c'est une méthode pour trouver tous les
tous les
tactiques échec prises menace dans
l'ordre comme ça on aura rien à rien
et moi une allez je tente une troisième
question après est-ce que c'est les
meilleurs ou pas on m'a dit de regarder
les faiblesses de l'adversaires ouais ça
c'est un très bon conseil
seau d'eau 64 510 ouais regardez les
philosophes de l'adversaire et peut-être
regarder aussi l'harmonie aussi dans ton
dans tes pièces tu vois de bien sortir
toutes tes pièces de faire en sorte que
toutes ces pièces jouent toutes les
pièces soient développées tu vois là par
exemple avec les Noirs c'est une
position que je conseillerais pas du
tout
à jouer pour un débutant parce que là il
y a un point débutant pour un joueur à
moins de 1500 pour un joueur
disons c'est pas débutant mais c'est pas
pas archi confirmé est-ce que c'est une
position très délicate à jouer pour le
noir c'est possible que les Noirs soient
mieux d'ailleurs j'en sais rien parce
qu'il y a un pion de plus mais les fous
sont pas sortis les tours non plus si on
Roque allèle roi on va se prendre des
gestes bref on va pas avoir d'abri
stable pour le roi
donc plutôt des choses de plus
harmonieuses et regarder se poser la
question quelle pièce ne joue pas chez
moi chez moi adversaire et essayer de
replacer ou d'activer les pièces qui ne
jouent pas
voilà ça pourrait être un troisième
conseil mais effectivement
regardez les faiblesses adversité aussi
un très bon français d'ailleurs juste
regarde je viens j'ai eu en fait le
message de deux gars de pièces comme qui
me parle en même temps là sur slack et
j'ai vu l'improvisation mais comme quoi
c'était pas ma faute
tout à l'heure les caméras enfin pas la
caméra mais les parties en fait les
parties sont disponibles que pour le
staff c'est marrant
elles sont cachées
et en fait mon compte il est pas staff
il faut qu'ils mettent le rôle là dessus
et en fait moi je suis pas débile
j'aurais pas marqué impossible de suivre
la partie je voyais qu'il est en train
de jouer mais je peux pas suivre la
partie c'est bizarre quoi donc là je
suis quelqu'un avec le compte de
cheeseccum fr donc maintenant ça marche
mais du coup donc voilà c'était des fois
tu doutes tu sais tu fais tellement
que les jouets le 10 + 2 là c'est
exactement la même chose on pouvait pas
suivre les parties des autres pour pas
que évidemment si personne peut suivre
les parties en direct du coup
bah ça va être compliqué de d'aider son
petit camarade si on a des moins
intentions donc voilà
il y a moins il y a beaucoup moins de
tri ça rangement etc
alors évidemment je râle toujours pour
ce cette fois où je suis parti en fait
tu vois il y a 6 minutes de pause je
pars 5 minutes et en fait j'ai pas été à
parier parce qu'en fait tu étais marqué
inactif et il te sort du tournoi c'est
automatique et après tu peux revenir
donc ça c'était vraiment dommage donc
j'ai pas été à Paris à la conduite mais
je t'assure qu'elle est la place j'étais
gagnant toutes les parties enfin je veux
dire j'ai la place pour faire beaucoup
plus donc vraiment c'est agréable parce
que déjà le format est quand même très
agréable et il y a vraiment aucun doute
quoi c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et
que vraiment ça joue pas terrible quoi
tu vois en plus vraiment il y a la place
pour se qualifier mais après moi je
pense que au moment où tu veux la calife
tu es un peu trembler un tu te disais
comme si je me qualifie je vais pas
pouvoir commenter avec stouf et je pense
que pour toi au fond de toi tu voulais
peut-être commencer
après la alors ennui là que j'ai vu
j'étais pas à Paris les autres comment
je me dis mais qu'est-ce qui se passe et
énervé alors moi j'ai gagné la dernière
quand même donc j'ai fait j'ai réussi à
quand même à jouer ce match j'ai perdu
enfin bref la totale tu sais où tu en
fait tu joues jusqu'au bout du truc ça
dure longtemps ces trucs hein quand tu
joues le match après pour se qualifier
et en fait quand tu le perds quand tu
pourras division 3 que tu perds tu es à
hauteur c'est toujours pour la division
2 que tu perds tu es en division 3 donc
tu as quand même quelque chose tu vois
et là c'était vraiment un peu rageant
mais bon écoute une belle expérience de
jeu c'est très sympa c'est ton raté et
ça permet tu vois des joueurs comme des
joueurs comme moi simplement de
voilà dans le dans le truc je veux pour
quelque chose c'est sympa tu vois parce
que c'est vrai que c'est champion de
chaise tour quand ils sont à 8 ou 10
bon ben c'est évidemment les meilleurs
joueurs du monde mais ça reste quand
même très très fermé comme comme circuit
tu vois ça fait là ça fait un peu genre
tournoi tu vois ça fait un peu il y a
Roland Garros qui arrive bientôt tu vois
Roland Garros tu as quand même tu as 128
joueurs au départ dans cette zone quand
même la chance à d'autres joueurs de
pouvoir faire des trucs sympas et
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est qu'on a Jules
Jules Moussa notre champion de France
qui va jouer la division 1 alors il a
perdu son match il était en Division 2
mais coup de bol première remplaçant et
repêcher et il mérite amplement sa
Californie alors ça va être ça va être
coton la vision il y a arrownia Nakamura
Kawana
notre petit on aura deux Français en
division
il est très il est capable de faire
beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais bon là
c'est c'est vrai que c'est le top du top
en terme de niveau mais en tout cas
c'est intéressant c'est un super
challenge pour lui il était très content
il m'a dit tout de suite j'essaierai de
j'essaierai je vais essayer de
je veux lui demander pour qu'il essaie
de venir nous dire un petit mot à la fin
des journées parce que ça peut être même
sympa d'avoir ses impressions et
toujours très simple on aura sur le
setup de d'obs là on aura tu sais les
trois petits on aura la la la scène avec
avec invité ouais c'est parce que je la
garderai ça peut être sympa de débriefer
avec Jules après ces matchs et Ali resa
évidemment notre petit allié Reza on
verra qui frappe parti je sais pas si ça
sera le favori mais en tout cas il sera
dans les favoris du la kidscope du 22 au
26 mai à ne pas rater sur cheescom tous
les jours à partir de 17 heures
et regardez moi ça va me D6 c'est très
chaud on voit bien que les blancs du jeu
c'est sûr alors après
alors tu gagnes des pions certes mais
alors qu'est-ce que ça fait peur ah il
joue dans la fuite il faut enlever cette
dame évidemment même si un jour tu
arrives à jouer quelque chose et tu
arrives à chasser la dame en fait sur le
long terme tu as toujours un fou qui est
très mauvais ici et ton roi qui reste au
centre tu es jamais vraiment l'abri
c'est-à-dire que là je suis Dame des
deux pour défendre à H2 et puis bah j'ai
pas envie de changer l'âme tu vois au
même là je vais peut-être du F5 dans
l'air il y a plein de choses et jolie
jolie F5 parce que ça attaque la tour
voilà
ça permet d'utiliser tous les chéquiers
avant tout ici et j'arrive pas à bouger
avec avec les rares et des cinq ouais
certes mais en fait ben j'ai plein de
thèmes quoi peut-être plus C4 même F5
toujours un coup qui se regarde parce
que ça ouvre toutes les diagonales les
colonnes et en fait au final le roi est
toujours hyper faible et c'est vrai que
sur le long terme là tu as un plan plus
mais sur le long terme c'est tellement
dur pour les Noirs il va jouer de la
musette je suppose il faut faire un
chantage pour faire la technique du
terroriste j'essaie de s'échanger les
dames
à tous les coups entame 7
pas mal quoi
je me développe quand même et je vais
essayer de faire foudre
en C3 alors peut-être pour garder la
même idée sauf que tu es tourage froide
et donc
maintenant je peux prendre un jeu ça
c'est la question
mais peut-être
ça a l'air ça a l'air très gourmand de
prendre après ça se calcule parce que
franchement
bah écoute
moi non plus je vois pas la D7
quoi que tu bouges plus trop après avoir
je sais pas moi j'ai jamais fait des
tours moi c'est plutôt
quand j'étais chez moi j'ai plutôt
branché sur la télé j'ai une grande télé
et j'ai branché le tournoi sur la télé
pour être en grand tu vois moi j'aime
pas regarder sur
je sais pas si c'est une bonne idée ou
pas mais j'ai l'impression de mieux voir
non mais tu sais ce qui s'est passé à
Berlin il s'est fait il s'est fait voler
son il parce qu'il était à Berlin il
était en voyage à ce tournoi Armageddon
il s'est fait easy il s'est fait
cambrioler sa chambre d'hôtel
plein ça dans un palace de Berlin et
donc il s'est fait piquer son donc c'est
pas drôle moi aussi j'ai un peu ça fait
sourire au départ mais en fait c'est pas
drôle vu qu'il s'est fait fatiguer pas
le choix il s'est fait piquer son ordi
qui est toujours embêtant tu vois c'est
qu'un ordi mais en fait c'est le
problème c'est que alors je sais pas
comment tu gères toi par rapport aux
sauvegardes on en fait de temps en temps
mais tu vois il court toujours un truc
quoi la femme il y a plein de trucs pas
quoi là je sais que maintenant moi j'ai
j'ai trois ordi c'est moi et
et j'ai des sauvegardes un peu dans
chaque truc et mais j'ai pas les mêmes
enfin je sais que je suis
déjà c'est jamais une bonne nouvelle de
se faire voler quelque chose que
quelqu'un rentre chez soi bon c'est
assez c'est assez dérangeant évidemment
mais en plus je leur dis ouais c'est
quand même beaucoup de travail tout pour
aujourd'hui
donc en fait déjà matériel ça fait chier
c'est un bon ordi etc mais au-delà de la
semaine matériel tu peux toujours
cracher c'est qu'en fait dessus il y a
beaucoup de base de travail d'échec et
tout la vie de toute ta vie si tu veux
de travail d'analyse de position
d'ouverture etc qui qui sont piqués
alors j'espère alors après ouais
[Musique]
je crois
que c'était pas des types non seulement
ils étaient malhonnêtes mais en plus ils
étaient pas particulièrement brillant et
je crois qu'ils se sont fait attraper
et ils sont fait attraper je sais pas si
la récupérer son ordi ou pas mais en
tout cas j'ai cette histoire de la part
de Gustave Stone qui commentait
l'événement et donc
voilà qui me racontait ça
et je sais plus quel est vraiment de
l'histoire mais je crois qu'ils ont fait
plus ou moins fait
ils ont fait plus ou moins attraper
alors est-ce que l'ordi avait déjà
disparu j'en sais rien il est pas mal
avec les Noirs
il a mangé H2 il a mis d'avancer 5 et
sur 15 mois il est il est ok ça a l'air
très solide
sur dame 5 de film contre-attaque comme
on en a
des contre-attaques rapides
dans l'histoire de la soudanité en deux
coups hop deux coups de cuillère à pot
et c'est déjà je vois pas comment tu
protèges B2 donc là il faut peut-être
faire un truc
je crois qu'il faut mettre un gros coup
de frein parce que même si je fais ça
bah c'est toujours c'est la même chose
en fait non mais je crois que tu es
obligé d'échanger les dames tu prends et
tu prends G6 et tu essaies de tenir
cette finale comme sur moi mais c'est
pas très marrant
c'est sûr qu'on jouait pas pour ça au
début avec les Blancs
aussi c'est
quand même
un peu mais ok
effectivement tu voulais le mater bah
écoute là tu tu joues pour
il y a eu ton D4 et il a pas du tout
changé les dames alors ton D4 c'est
c'est le coup du gars qui qui veut
continuer quoi
alors que
tu vois mais bon après bon elles ont 3
minutes chacun c'est quand même dur de
de de critiquer parce que franchement
entre les quatre ça a l'air quand même
d'être enfin ça a la pression tu vois
regarde la pièce
mais
ok donc dame on a la chose aussi donc
avec la jauge c'est quand même plus
facile de la même ça se voit franchement
tu vois que là ça y est ça se voit que
que maintenant c'est les Noirs la jauge
alors on a pas de ligne d'ordi mais on a
à jauge qui nous aide beaucoup qui vous
aide aussi pour voir mais ne vous étiez
pas trop
enfin félicite de pas regarder quoi
c'est quand même plus
regardez mais
maintenant ça commence un petit peu à
tourner cette histoire parce que je peux
manger un pion ah ouais encore manger un
pion parce que sinon c'est moi qui te
mange
faible et bien regarde pas du tout je
crois que tu as entendu il m'a dit 7
express
il y a trois pays à l'époque j'avais
plus de 2007 il m'a proposé
mais je trouvais que bon c'était trop
les points lourds quand tu as plus de
vitesse
en Chine avec le décalage horaire avec
des joueurs sous classés si tu peux
faire tu peux en une semaine tu peux
perdre pour pas facile quoi
non il y a pas d'échec là c'était en
prise mais oui l'idée est là
et je crois qu'il est c'est terminé pour
cette vanille petite forme
qui qui est pas en forme là dans ce dans
ce dans ce match pour l'instant et tu
vois dans ce format là il y a quatre
joueurs
tout le monde se joue c'était un joueur
déjà qui déconne et qui est pas en forme
ça va très très vite ah ouais ça peut
être très vite parce que tu fais un même
un petit zéro sur 4 ou même ça doit
mieux c'est quand même le numéro 2 de
son équipe
même si il fait un et demi ou deux sur
quatre c'est pas bien quoi enfin c'est
pas bien
c'est au niveau en face est très fort
mais normalement tu es censé faire mieux
tu es le numéro de l'équipe là tu
comprends le numéro 4
elle est importante cette partie et deux
joueurs qui ont perdu la première donc
après tu peux les perdre aussi ils
peuvent perdre la confiance tu vois tu
peux ça peut aller vite en plus
est-ce que tu fais un petit un petit
tour rapide ou comme tu veux écoute moi
j'aime bien cette partie j'ai fait avec
le proposer puis je me suis dit non et
quand même sympa regardons une minute
contre deux je peux aussi derrière on
regarde la fin je peux vous faire à
l'aveugle si vous voulez un petit truc
plus pour autant
je trouve que
jungle et ben elle met la pression grave
après neige
juste vérifier
tu peux me le dire toi s'il te plaît
[Musique]
WordPress indienne
un style c'est votre signe française
[Musique]
il est pas mal
mais bon d'accord
ça va se décanter quand
là dans les prochaines minutes regardez
comment c'est chaud cette partie alors
évidemment trois pions de plus pour les
Noirs mais le roi dans les commentaires
et encore du jeu au moins en pratique
c'est chaud là je me blesse de manger en
dessin avec du puits
sur la colonne là ici il faut réagir
avec les Noirs Mb4 menaces
alors pourquoi
bien c'est dur à dire
parce que ça a l'air d'être un très bon
coup
ça a l'air d'être très bien peut-être tu
peux juste rien faire quelque chose
avant qu'il arrive
mais après prise j'ai envie de faire
[__] et tu peux pas prendre parce
qu'il y a toujours mat donc
on prend C4 il y a évidemment le
terrible tour des 8 et chaque et mat
est-ce que n'importe quoi
ça paraît logique aussi
en Bullet il est alors je connais pas le
niveau de lipping loup en
en Bullet tout ça mais ça donne il est
hyper dangereux
il veut 5 fourchette
quand on prend il a il aura lâché de
l'Est mais après tout il a 30 jours de
plus donc c'est pas mal surtout ça
bloque un petit peu la Dame Blanche
essayer de souffler un peu quoi
comment est-ce que je peux souffler
pas évident pas évident du tout comment
il peut il peut pas traîner il a 15
secondes 15 secondes pour 18h c'est le
money time et tout peut se passer
ce qui va arriver ouais c'est la
dégringolade complet chez
le hipping et c'est ce qui va arriver
échec attention
c'est pas mal ça il est fort disons
trouve des coups incroyables avec les
secondes
attention quand même
d'être bien vu ou pas
[Musique]
c'est terminé
en fait ton roi il est trop faible
et énorme surprise
ouais mais la position
en fait c'est pas du tout
[Musique]
dans mes pronostics mais on irait avoir
parce que la valeur est pas mal dans la
pose que j'ai vu pas mal il a dû faire
un peu retourner
je crois
les pousser le furieux maintenant le roi
revient et la tour peut pas participer
oh là quel gaffe il fallait pousser tout
simplement
c'est simple encore
ça va gagner parce que je veux ça
qui va gagner
pour pouvoir manger
encore
position direct
je pense qu'il a il a raté
mais là attend mais même je crois que ça
gagne on reprend
oui
de prendre de la tour et maintenant je
te coupe et
si tu prends de la tour en deux je fais
tourner cette échec tu es obligé d'aller
sur la colonne
de deux colonnes il y a
le roi et le pion ici entre la tour sur
la 5e rangée pour couper et on sort le
roi c'est le petit pont
qui est en train de l'emporter
et ça va être le point d'égalisation
proche chinois vous l'avez dit Tiger ce
qui reviennent salut à toi Sophie Oslo
é
ça a perdu alors juste rapidement si tu
veux je te laisse voir
quand j'ai vu la position
que c'était non non
je sais pas comment c'était possible il
en a deux j'ai vu
et j'ai vu une position comme ça
non j'ai vu après la pause ah oui bah ça
c'est comment on dit effectivement
les plus forts chez les Chinois
ça doit nier
ton problème
un bon avantage
c'était la position où il y avait
un peu
alors je sais plus je crois que c'était
dans cette position là un truc comme ça
ici je crois que j'ai eu les blancs
alors peut-être que je me trompe
complètement mais j'avais l'impression
que
j'avais il y avait moyen d'embêter un
peu quoi ouais bien sûr bien
un petit peu
moins clair
je peux me créer un petit abri
et jouer et peut-être qu'avec ton foot
casse noir etc
alors je place les caméras pendant pour
la ronde 3
petite pause après avant ce match
mi-temps
on aura déjà Stéphane on aura déjà un 4e
7 ça c'est sûr même s'il y a 4-0 et
ensuite on enchaîne avec le streamer
américain le plus fort de tous les temps
Ikaru Nakamura ça sera le match des
côtes d'AMS vers 18h30 je crois
18h
à tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus avec Laurent
alors qu'il y a 4 4 dans ce match entre
les Indian yogi et les changa Tigers et
ben la ronde 3 qui va commencer alors
vous les avez écrit sous nos caméras
donc Prague jumen
et pranesh contre Gucci et là ça
commence ça devient plus
serré entre guillemets ouais c'est ça
entre
Prague remarque Prague et favoris
évidemment face à la championne du monde
mais c'est la championne du monde donc
ça va pas être évident franchement
depuis le début elle fait quand même un
très très une belle composition
franchement
et là elle vient de perdre contre unes
mais elle fait vraiment très bons
résultats c'est pas sous-estimé je vous
rappelle qu'elle a quand même battu mvl
an dangereuse
et on voit Prague qui joue un petit
fiancetto et voilà ouais c'est ça il
veut mettre la pression il a envie de la
de la gagner cette partie
assez clairement
alors
je peux pas jouer des 5
c'est vrai donc les Noirs vont réussir à
échanger ce pion C contre le pion des
voilà elle prend bon ben elle remet le
pion de pragos centre c'est un peu
étonnant de prendre comme ça aussi tôt
parce que maintenant on peut faire G6 ou
G7 j'ai l'impression mais non sont déjà
très bien
on va voir
sur les grandes diagonales ah ben elle
aussi tiens elle a bien raison
il faut un petit peu de jalousie pas
trop mais
c'est bien tu vois
copier copier son adversaire quand il
fait les choses bien
contre un pion des
donc comment dire comment allez-vous ces
positions
[Musique]
le cavalier vient en C3 ok ouais sinon
tu faisais à 5 à 4 si le cavalier venait
en D2 donc ça c'est logique
tu vas faire qui est BD moi je trouve
que les Noirs je préfère les Noirs ici
pourquoi parce que j'ai plus de pions
ensemble voilà j'ai pu en D comme tu
l'as dit j'ai pu enlever contre le pion
B et c'est plus mobile ça donne plus de
d'options clairement mais bon
objectivement c'est à peu près
d'ailleurs la jauge ne me contredit pas
c'est à peu près équilibré mais je
trouve ça en pratique un peu je prends
les Noirs voilà
c'est le 4 ça peut être possible changer
les pièces
sont jamais trop on va dire mécontents
d'échanger ses cavaliers ici pour mettre
la pression sur le clouage entre
guillemets
il faut G2
intéressant
par contre là j'aime pas
si jamais on sait jamais mais dans cette
vente là avec cavaler C3 par contre je
suis pas du tout fan4 je suis pas fan du
tout de l'idée de jouer les bêtises pour
du coup je vois à 5 à 4 parce qu'en fait
sur la 5 je pense que je pourrais même à
4 et tu auras un problème sur
bah le pion à 5 sur le long terme en
fait
mais bon je suis pas fan euh
ici il y a eu cavalucate qui m'a l'air
plus naturel dame c'est deux qui avaler
prend faut prendre et en fait
je remets en caméra F6 pour rien voir de
faible et c'est vrai que regarde sur le
long terme j'ai ce j'ai ce plan à 5 à 4
qui va qui va revenir c'est ça on aimer
le caméra
et maintenant que c'est bien écoute ça
devient une menace
[Musique]
qui commence à être un peu concrète quoi
on est quasi certainement on va le voir
vous allez voir c'est pas si ça va être
tout de suite ou un peu plus tard
et bonjour à tous Un enchat ton ignore
personne il y a des amitiés qui se
vident dans le chat c'est beau les
échecs nous sommes une grande famille
et salut à toi lance Lindberg
merci de nous rejoindre ça devient très
chaud on a quatre partout on va avoir
forcément de l'action ensuite on a
Nakamura bref on va passer une fin de
samedi plutôt agréable et plutôt sympa
[Musique]
d'Internet avec Magnus et il a battu au
dernier tournoi de Champions League donc
il s'échange vraiment les victoires la
dernière partie qui était qui était un
petit peu comment tu peux appeler ça
tu as vu le match hier c'était prana
encore prana 20 tout à l'heure je
parlais de la partie de de wedi contre
mais il y a aussi un autre truc que on a
pas vu c'est que prana va jouer contre
donc c'était un chinois alors je sais
plus lequel et
une finale qui était a priori légal et
en fait il a rangé deux il tourne enfin
avec les Blancs et un Cavalaire marche 3
et le chinois il fait froid
et miskika
et abandon
quasiment bon alors l'avant
l'inconvénient c'est ça c'est ce que tu
viens de dire c'est Emmaüs c'est un
congé en Internet après il y a pas la
pagaille quand il reste 10 secondes ou
les joueurs balancent les pièces à
gauche à droite l'arbitre et de toute
façon il est complètement débordé enfin
il s'est en général les arbitres ils
interviennent pas et donc voilà ça
devient la pagaille et c'est pas c'est
pas des belles fins de parties aussi
donc bon ben on a trouvé cette solution
d'incrément mais c'est vrai qu'à un
moment il faut un Armageddon pour
départager les joueurs donc
voilà il y a eu cette magazon
qui a fait ce mois-ci avec le petit jus
Ron qui va avec avec mon norvégien je
parle norvégien je sais dire beaucoup
beaucoup de gros mots
de France
départage pour le titre de champion de
France je sais plus où est-ce que
c'était tout
Etienne
l'armée
il me flag à l'Armageddon ou j'ai une
pièce de plus à la fin mais de toute
façon clairement il avait j'avais 10
secondes il avait 20 et il était gagnant
à ce moment-là donc tu es là clairement
fait n'importe quoi pour me flaguer la
partie était mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu rageant parce que tu es là tu tu
reviens et voilà mais j'avais pas dominé
cette partie clairement donc pas de pas
trop de regret parce que il joue à la
fin pour flaguer et d'ailleurs il y a
aucune même après la partie il y a
aucune rancune parce que ces jeux
d'Armageddon j'avais qu'à jouer plus
vite
c'est la règle c'est du chaos etc
pour le coup mais je me rappelle de
tournois quand j'étais jeune je jouais
les rapides j'ai entendu pour la
première fois un type qui se plaignait
et pas incrément à l'époque et donc ça
jouait sur les pendules les vieilles
pendules et manque un type le flag
l'autre dit attends c'est pas sport il
dit tu as qu'à jouer plus vite bah ouais
mais l'ambiance quoi tu vois mais
l'ambiance plus vite c'est la règle
c'est vrai qu'au final ben ouais bah
écoute c'est parti du jeu hein le temps
partenaire pendule fait partie
intégrante du jeu et encore plus en
magasin après je suis d'accord avec avec
tout ça
un peu sous condition parce que tu peux
servir de ça pour mettre la pression etc
plein de choses mais à la fin quand tu
as une finale retour par exemple
là juste flaguer je trouve ça marche
quand même tu vois ce genre de choses
surtout en IRL
mais enfin je sais pas franchement si je
devais je compte toi bon moi j'aurais
pas compte toi pour être pour un type
champion de France mais imaginons on
a on a tous les deux elles sont toutes
[Rires]
pour le coup je trouve que c'est c'est
OK dans l'arbre à partir de tienne il y
a rien à voir c'est une partie qui est
qui a été jouée et cetera surtout qu'il
allait noir il doit faire nul ouais mais
surtout en fait à la fin en fait juste
quand quand imaginons tu as vraiment un
croissant qu'on croit tout et que tu
joues ça ça juste c'est un truc que
j'aime pas c'est que je vais toujours un
peu sticker mais mais à part ça bah oui
je pense à partir du jeu
et puis voilà chacun joueur son sa
partie comme comme il l'entend il peut
jeter la pression et c'est le mieux
jouer l'échec voilà il y a un peu de
tout quoi alors moi je regarde le petit
coup F3 pour Joker je crois qu'il y
avait des F4
c'est pas l'idée de prophète
elle joue très serré hein
Juventus
5 mais aussi il s'offre la case des
quatre
[Musique]
tu pouvais faire ça maintenant il y a du
chaos enfin il y a du il y a du Fisher
là ne marche plus tu peux pas l'arbitre
comme ça parce que comme tu as de la
crémant et ben tu peux prouver toi au
bout de 30 coups tu vois si clairement
mais normalement tu démontres toi-même
grâce à l'incrément en fait tu joues et
ça au cas où mais par contre
mon Armageddon ça c'est spécial faudrait
voir les règles mais c'est vrai que
après je pense que il y a aussi le
je sais pas tu en penses quoi toi tu
flattes toi pour un titre
non mais c'est une question parce qu'en
fait en vrai c'est pas clair
en vrai
parce que 30 secondes non s'il en reste
3 oui ok oui d'accord oui c'est quand tu
rentres dans la finale il lui reste
vraiment plus rien
qui lui reste trois secondes dans la
finale etc ok tu peux le flag mais c'est
vrai que si la réponse
[Musique]
il a un vin ça dépend pas non plus j'en
sais rien tu vois c'est compliqué moi je
me verrais pas trop
au final j'aime pas mais de l'autre côté
ben après ça dépend aussi peut-être de
moins de harcèle et ça dépend aussi
peut-être de comment la partie s'est
déroulée quoi aussi donc il y a plein de
mais bon si tu étais gagnante tu as
voulu jouer vite pour mettre la pression
tu vois et que il se retrouve sans tente
à une minute de plus bon ben ouais mais
ça fait partie de ta stratégie aussi que
tu vas pouvoir flaguer à la fin donc
après je peux te dire que que contre
Nakamura si la 30 secondes je vais la
jouer en fait Naka il va alors lui IRL
pas RL il a pas de race je pense que lui
il flag quoi qu'il arrive mais en fait
c'est pas assez même pas c'est pas avoir
de
tu vois c'est juste c'est je pense que
il le prend pas mal quand il se fait
flag en fait j'espère en tout cas non
en fait moi j'avais entendu maroline
Naka qui disait en fait non face à la
partie du jeu enfin juste c'est les gens
comprennent pas pourquoi pourquoi
ben on continue c'est parti là etc c'est
Naruto stream et dit bah en fait non
c'est parce que moi je m'en fous moi je
joue quoi et donc je pense que Naka il
irait rien enfin il dirait rien il y a
rien je sais pas comment ça se passe
surtout si hyper confirmé comme nous
mais
ouais mais je pense que sur un vrai
chéquier n'a pas pour flaga
c'est quoi cette question jack and gars
écoutez bien chacun de gardien
tu t'es masquée encore une fois oh là là
il a qu'un gars quand même merci
non mais en fait après c'est facile
simple
[Musique]
[Rires]
de
plus proche que j'amène d'ailleurs
je viens de perdre 0,3 là
c'est bon
j'étais à 23,99,3 mais non avant le mois
de mai
et j'ai pas eu de participer
et donc là je suis rentré
Laurent il croit pas quoi il n'y croit
pas mais pourquoi tu vas pas jouer une
partie je sais pas où ben j'ai pas de
partie là en fait j'ai mal Ligue
espagnole qui qui m'a proposé de jouer
mais c'est au canari bon moi j'ai
déménagé maintenant sur le continent
donc bon
il faut attendre
la partie tu prends un arbitre et tu
fais la fête en même temps que la partie
parce que quand on se trouve extension
il y a pas de risque
mais non mais je vais jouer un tournant
en juin mi-juin le 16 juin exactement et
normalement si tout va bien je vois 1500
tu gagnes 08
comme disait sur le stream de Yoshi il
faut absolument pas que je joue un
indien quoi juste un 1500 mais un vrai
un vrai espagnol quoi c'est
bien un indien qui dépasse pas la table
tu sais que tu vois pas dans la partie
je le prends pas
mais bon ok ok je suis quand même pas
mal là
c'est un petit peu
en équipe et je jouais un 22/50 puis en
2004 puis en 1850 et j'ai dit trop
risqué
c'est bon j'en ai marre là ça y est
il est toujours mieux Prague il pousse
il pousse est-ce qu'on va avoir une
autre partie moi je pense que j'ouvre
une journée elle va défendre cette
partie je pense qu'on va défendre moi je
pense pas
ok
je la vois je la vois pas
cette partie elle est tenace notre ami a
joué le jaune on va voir ok alors tac
est-ce que tu veux voir je regarde
rapidement pour te dire la Wailly qui
joue contre
une belle partie
à moi ça me casse ça m'empêche de dormir
excuse-moi non s'il te plaît arrête
souvent quand tu manges tout à la fin tu
pars tu peux pas faire 7 mais il y a
peut-être moyen de faire un truc du styl
droit G8 ou de défendre F7 et de manger
C3
il y a quand même encore des petites
complications
[Musique]
quand même un peu même même les finales
souvent
[Musique]
ok elle est pas très marrante peut-être
le Salvateur chinois
contre contre
et là je n'ai pas encore commencé à
calculer mais je vois plein de pièces
sur le roi blanc
matériellement on est égalité il y a un
pion de plus pour les blancs
on est d'accord
il y a plein de nuls Avec cette position
avec cette
je sais plus comment c'est exactement
comment ça marche mais je sais qu'il y a
des perpétuelles avec un roi qui vivent
jusque là un truc comme ça non je sais
plus comment ça se passe je sais plus
comment c'est j'avais déjà vu ça mais je
connais rien
un petit rock apparemment ça a perdu
enfin peut-être pas quand même beaucoup
hyper étonnant et là
donc fourchette force la prise
regardez les pièces blanches là c'est
terrible
quelque chose comme ça tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
je te respecte pas
alors si tu prends le dommage car on
attend
et il y a eu cavalier pour venir un peu
réparer les trous sur case noir
dans H4 je peux pas défendre depuis un
je crois qu'elle horreur
F4 regardez petit échec et matte en un
coup joli
tu sais non tu sais ce qu'on fait sur
quel G2 juste pour rentrer on se faufit
on fait damage 2 je trouve ça plus joli
avec la dame c'est magnifique
tf4 G5 donc j'ai battu prend H3 et c'est
ma 2 partout
[Musique]
donc il a juste des cartes donc il sort
ses pièces donc maintenant il y a plus
le problème de clouage donc le fou a été
bloqué et genre puis on prend je fais
cavaler prendre un plus possible à cause
de puis on prend tout simplement oui
3 mais bon ça a l'air enfin ça sent que
que la position allait pas bonne dame à
5 après il se défend tu vois mais non
d'un point H3 c'est monstrueux au début
je te dis hein avant que tu fasses le
haut
H3 mais effectivement
fait mal effectivement quand
c'est une partie celle-là attendez
chinois ils font des parties comme ça
franchement
cette partie là sur le thème pas mal à
la partie de de
ouh là il est content 3 sur 3 il est
chaud
c'est vraiment ah ouais il est content
et toi c'est pas mal à la partie de wedi
contrepreneur c'est le même genre
qui sont elles sont préparés sur ce
thème là partie est-ce qu'on a autre
chose comme parc comme ça c'est terminé
Vesali
ok mais
est-ce qu'il se voit on va dire bonjour
à nos amis on a éteint de Saya ma petite
banane avec sa chaîne twitch salut ma
petite balade et Algérie un champion de
France junior volant
bravo à LG hello qui a gagné Joseph
Girel de Marseille le Marseillais le
limougeot Marseillais et oui originaire
de Limoges mais à Marseille c'est pas la
même ambiance de salle de ambiance et
champion de France junior largement
mérité très très beau tournoi j'ai suivi
un petit peu ça c'est pas la première
fois que j'envoie le français
c'est pas la première fois il avait été
champion de France l'année dernière en
moins de 18
et donc bravo très belle catégorie en
plus c'est moins de 20 hein
voilà il a il a été très bon
et ouais trois tournois c'est en
contrôle
il a gagné la partie décisive contre
malboyet qui est en qui quasi grand
maître mal Boyer assez rapidement en
gagnant en une vingtaine de coups donc
tu auras tout en contrôle de notre ami
de Limoges
salut à toi alors est-ce que nous tient
ça je viens de jouer dans la ferme
entière elle est pas bien
alors
il va tomber mais le 4 4 4 4
c'est la partie
junior avec moins de succès quand même
tu vis ça petite banane
et Johanna Joseph girl c'est le style
et dis pas que tu as envie de me jouer
elle dirait alors attention
des partages flags attention ça va mal
tourner je te mets 600 secondes pendant
je mettrai 600 secondes pendant la
partie
alors bon
pour trois pions et j'ai encore un pion
je suis vivant encore mais je crois que
elle tient mais ouais c'est chaud encore
là
exact 5 peut-être alors effectivement
attends je peux essayer de pousser aussi
si tu vas trop loin
ça je commence à aimer les méchant sac à
gagner
du vent je suis là hein
comment elle se battre 3 secondes
attention
lier
roi des deux propositions
elle a très très bien défendu elle est
sacrément tenace notre ami je vous
l'avais dit et joue le gars C6
attention
quelque part il faut choisir la bonne
case je sais pas laquelle c'est
ouh là là regardez-moi ça elle peut
gagner elle peut gagner B6 va arriver la
jauge qui s'enflamme évidemment il y a
B7 qui arrive maintenant T7 tour des 8
menaces et il a complètement craqué
pragué ça serait pas le tour du match
parce que là ça ferait une victoire pour
jouer à une jeune face aux meilleurs
joueurs mastouage 6 tour des 8 tours D8
c'est terminé tournez vite joué elle est
là elle est là le jaune
retour des 8 c'est fini et ouais il peut
faire non et oui il a pris trop de
risques
après je comprends tu as poussé toute la
partie
prends la pièce tu prends les pions et
tu vois psychologiquement tu arrives pas
à
ouais mais enfin quand tu vois quand tu
vois je bouge la tour elle fait 6 tu te
dis ouais c'est dur de de vraiment
accepter ton sort et tu dis ok pour
faire nul quoi attaquer une pièce de
plus ici et
boîte typiquement j'aurais je parie et
j'aurais perdu aussi parce que je suis
comme ça j'arrive pas à me non j'aurais
fait
j'aurais répété
bien avant même
trop d'aventure salut à toi je me dis
ton problème c'est un projet si ça gagne
ça ah ça gagne ça crée
moi j'ai 6 non tour à 5
et tourgé 8 maintenant
c'est pas sûr que ça soit gagnant
tout proche non il fait tout à 8 comment
il gagne
avec le roi
si Roger vite c'est maths
je suis tout à
fait
nos amis indiens heureusement
elle fait très très mal cette victoire
de juventjun contre Prague un peu le
tournant parce que là même
il serait pas
à ce niveau là alors attends juste
rapidement donc de score vous l'avez ici
en 7,5 pour pour les Chinois les
Shanghai Tigers
donc pour la dernière ronde je vous
donne un appareil moins donc je pense
que tout le monde un peu
les connais hein c'est pas très
compliqué il suffit que tu parles banal
banane il en sait rien mais les autres
normalement alors c'est le 1 contre 1 le
2 contre le 2 etc donc ça fera Prague
blanc contre Wailly ça doit ni blanc
contre Juventus
blanc contre
veshali et Louis pink contre pranesh je
vais de ce pas vous mettre les
apparisants
et puis bon gros avantage Chine
évidemment je regarde Tigers deux points
d'avance et Big siffle est-ce qu'il vaut
mieux perdre comme ça à cause de trop de
l'agressivité quand on veut forcer le
gain ou est-ce qu'il vaut mieux jouer de
façon conservatrice comme ça chacun a
son style alors le style de saut il perd
très peu mais également et le style de
Prague qu'on vient de voir il y a une
plus de parties mais en plus aussi
c'est des choix
c'est des choix voilà c'est la nature
aussi il est c'est pas un flambeur
j'ai mon naturel moi je suis naturel
flambeur en vrai mais voilà ça ça
et ouais mais parfois j'ai des petits
craquage quand même
et je comprends que c'est pas mon
avantage tu vois donc
j'essaye de
j'essaye d'enlever ça salut killer Joël
qui me demande si je joue les
championnats de France cette année et
bien oui
la participation nationale qui sera et
les championnats de France d'ailleurs on
avait parlé avec cet officiel n'hésitez
pas à vous inscrire c'est à l'Alpe
d'Huez bon mythique Tour de France
Alpes Duez tour à vélo là petite rando
ça va c'est quand même rare de jouer
dans les endroits aussi beaux on sait
comme on l'avait dit on l'avait dit on
était d'accord Stéphane
c'est dans des endroits assez chaud donc
il y avait une lime plein de fois il y a
tu vois c'est vraiment des et là c'est
vrai que bah elle peut être c'est la
montagne quoi c'est l'art frais et tout
et le cadre change c'est vraiment cool
de faire un tournoi dans ces conditions
tu vois franchement
moi qui le fait une fois dans ma vie
c'était en 2008
à pauvre
et je l'ai pas refait après la chocolat
de France et donc moi qui joue jamais et
ben écoute j'ai pensé à faire j'ai pensé
et puis j'ai dit finalement non
je ne joue pas là
je vais faire déjà
trois tournois peut-être c'est beaucoup
pour moi moi je joue quasiment plus à
l'été enfin juste parce que je peux pas
passer l'été à faire que de jouer quoi
je suis pas trop
[Musique]
donc ça sera le
c'est le prochain gros événement
français
ce fameux Top 16 mais je crois qu'on
n'est pas dans la même dans la même
poule que
Marseille et Marseille risque de finir
pour le basse je crois
terminer en poudre
ils sont pas mauvais mais Marseille
poulet normalement
je crois les promus comme ça en tout cas
moi je serai là je vous regarderai tous
d'un œil
je crois qu'il y aura une une
retransmission sur cette même chaîne du
Norway de chasse peut-être que je je
m'avance un petit peu alors du coup je
peux peut-être vous en parler on aura le
Norway de chasse j'ai pas les dates sous
les yeux c'était du
c'est du vraiment du 30 au 10 comme le
comme le Top 16
grosso modo
mais du coup on s'est posé la question
de savoir est-ce que éventuellement on
pourrait retransmettre la poule haute et
la poule basse à la fin dans watchesse
et peut-être je me ferai une joie de te
regarder Laurent
c'est une bonne idée c'est un beau
tournoi tu vois
peut-être à lire ça dans ça je crois
qu'il joue dans Honor witch mais tu as
quand même des des très très bons
joueurs tu as les meilleurs joueurs
français et les meilleurs joueurs enfin
certains des tops joueurs étrangers
vraiment avec des joueurs à plus de 2007
Asnières et easy Penko des joueurs comme
ça parfois il y a des surprises des
joueurs du top mondial qui arrive
donc beau tournoi à suivre et puis en
plus quand on a français et bien sûr
c'était pas possible
pour Cannes qui viendra se frotter
l'année prochaine en Top 16
on jouera pas mais on va se préparer
pour être en forme l'année prochaine
c'est normal faut être beau joueur
je suis un participant je suis pas de
France jeune mais c'est très bien tu as
pu découvrir tout ça
à jeun Agen ou c'est la plus grosse
manifestation quand on parle du droit
français c'est la plus grosse
manifestation française avec je crois
cette année encore batturé de 1800
jeunes c'est devenu une usine avec des
avec beaucoup de coach beaucoup
d'accompagnateurs et donc très très bel
événement j'étais allé en
c'est plus quand les coupes une année
ça devait être
2021 je crois
et donc voici 2021 et donc ouais là on
voit le changement quand même on a
changé de braquer on est on est sur un
truc je sais pas si tu allais récemment
non on a changé de braquer type ils
arrivent les coachs tu vois chaque jeune
à quelqu'un aller voir tu vois c'est
quand même c'est c'est assez
impressionnant c'est
il y a de plus en plus de gens mais
c'est bien moi j'ai toujours été
évidemment pour l'ouvrir un maximum de
jeunes et pour donner cette expérience
un maximum de jeunes c'est
et voilà ça fait un événement magnifique
tout ça c'est
l'événement incontournable de l'année et
pour ces jeunes qui qui rêvent de
d'y aller représenter leur club c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment cool et je sais
que même moi en tant que coach chaque
année pendant les qualifications pour ce
plafond c'est toujours vraiment beaucoup
de pression pour ce tournoi parce que
tout le monde veut y aller et ben c'est
le championnat de France
via la Fédération c'est le rôle d'une
chose qui se font online c'est vraiment
l'enregis de fédération
je suis absolument d'accord mais après
[Musique]
générations de club quand même oui bien
sûr que l'idée c'est quand même d'amener
à la fin
c'est d'amener à la fin les gens en club
et de jouer autre chose il y a un truc
social aussi tu vois
la pratique du jeu d'échec du truc
social d'aller en club et les gens
donc voilà mais effectivement la
pratique online mène à la pratique en
plus les deux l'un ne va pas s'en sortir
et oui l'année où a pas gagné alors qui
gagne
la pression évidemment
plein de choses à faire tu as plein de
gamins et puis c'est le rêve un peu de
chaque enfant
des podiums des trucs ça reste toujours
quelque chose de vraiment vraiment cool
donc moi je les joue en quelques jours
en plein de fois je sais jamais rien
fait ma meilleure place j'ai dû faire
tu vas rire
[Rires]
je pense que j'ai même un record
non j'ai un autre truc j'ai
donc j'ai 5 championnats plus 4 parties
à vaincu donc 49 parties consécutives à
vaincu et là et là et séries en cours a
priori je vais pas le truc c'est j'ai
arrêté sur ça voilà tu vois donc j'ai
fait cinq mais j'ai la première la
première fois où j'ai fait ce truc avec
j'ai pas gagné parce que
déjà tout petit déjà je faisais trop de
nuls mais cinq championnats consécutifs
à vaincus + 4 parties consécutive
j'avais
compté ça et je pense que
c'est c'est dans le
et la gamme de Prague moi j'avais la cam
et du coup vous entendez peut-être les
arbitres qui leur parlaient alors moi je
l'avais pas en fait c'est ça que là j'ai
les caméras des joueurs à chaque fois et
donc c'est quoi ton meilleur résultat du
coup donc c'était pas c'était pas je
crois que mon meilleur résultat j'ai dû
faire top 10 une fois d'accord ok
[Musique]
en fait
déjà moi j'avais bon c'est pas une
excuse j'étais pas très bon jeune et de
base et même en fait
pour se qualifier c'était dur parce
qu'on avait quand même plein de gros
clubs en Côte d'Azur et par exemple ben
juste en minime l'année où je me suis
qualifié
on était peut-être au département
7 ou 8 même 9 joueurs à plus de 2000
pour 3 places
en fait c'est de quoi enfin ils ont
décidé de non mais ils ont décidé
d'ouvrir plus c'est un choix comme les
championnats du monde championne moi mon
époque je jouais les championnats du
monde il y avait un type par pays il y
avait le champion du pays je jouais un
portugais le lendemain joueur italien
ensuite un Brésilien mais il n'y avait
pas deux quoi alors parfois il y avait
deux quand le il y avait un qui avait
été champion du monde de l'année d'avant
donc il prenait un autre du pays en fait
je veux dire tu es arrivé il y avait
deux rues il y avait deux Russes et le
reste c'était un un par pays et c'est
vrai que ça donnait un truc alors je
sais pas quel est le mieux est-ce que
c'est bien d'ouvrir ou pas
je pensais pas mal il faut pas trouver
non plus en fait c'est compliqué quoi
alors moi je trouve ça aussi dans le
dans le sens en fait que que maintenant
enfin en tout cas moi quand j'étais
coach quand je voyais les minimes chez
nous tu en avais souvent un ou deux à
2000 et le reste c'était 1700 en fait et
en fait ça veut dire que le niveau enfin
je trouvais qu'il avait quand même assez
laissé
et en plus donc tu avais peut-être je
sais pas au lieu d'en avoir trois comme
moi j'avais il avait là il avait 10
et tu avais des joueurs à 1300 qui se
qualifié en minimum
une fois dans la vie c'était en minime
et après j'ai fait les deux cadets les
deux juniors et avant j'arrivais jamais
voilà donc après j'ai progressé vers
minimes en fait à ce moment là que j'ai
commencé à progresser mais c'est vrai
qu'au début j'étais un petit peu lent la
détente
mais bon c'est la persévérance
c'est la persévérance petite alerte je
regarde sur le sur notre écran notre
aliaser qui joue à la fin du à la fin du
mois et bien il est en train de il est
en train de faire le doubler là il est
en train de battre il y a des pomyachi
complètement gagnant dans notre petit et
donc il a déjà battu Ding il y a
quelques jours donc il est en train de
dans la tête du tournoi tout simplement
je peux pas suivre
parce que si je fais ça je vais tout cas
d'aller voir
je pense qu'elle est rasage je pense que
psychologiquement il veut tout gagner
hein et nepo il est un peu peut-être
avec le match c'est marqué il enchaîne
avec ça et puis il enchaîne la partie
enfin plusieurs parties pas forcément
bonne et une époque en fait
il faut qu'il essaie de débuter un peu
la classe parce que là il peut sombrer
[Musique]
très honnêtement
d'aller jouer ce tournoi après le match
là les deux qui jouent mal bon ben c'est
pas c'est pas surprenant tellement de
tension en plus le match aller au bout
du bout tu vois c'était pas bon c'est
pas dingue
bon après ils ont envie de jouer quand
c'est vrai que le grand cheese tour
c'est quand même un gros tournoi dans
l'année
je fais un petit test je vais ouvrir la
fenêtre
ce que j'ai jamais fait encore
les deux matchs entre les dommage
aujourd'hui aussi ces deux Max au monde
sauf de navigation locale plus les gros
pays d'accord ouais d'accord donc c'est
pas si ouvert que ça le Championnat du
Monde jeune d'accord
je pensais que c'était un peu plus
ouvert que ça non non je crois que
championnat de non il me semble qu'il y
a une règle avec peut-être championnat
d'Europe que tu peux y aller par tes
propres moyens si tu fais top 10
national un truc comme ça ou il y a
comme ça je suis pas sûr du tout
peut-être que il sait j'irai où moi j'ai
vu non mais tu vois il y a la liste des
sélectionnés qui a été publié donc c'est
pas ça en fait je pense parce qu'en fait
de la Fédération il y a si tu veux les
joueurs qui sont autorisés à participer
à leur frais les joueurs qui
ont le cursus parce qu'il y a un
problème d'entraînement mis en place par
la fédé donc ceux qui ont droit à ça
ceux qui ont les championnats du monde
des championnats d'Europe payés voilà ce
genre de choses et donc j'ai pas eu
l'impression que le top 10 puisse y
aller mais bon
après c'est certainement aussi chaque
pays qui choisit ses règles parce qu'en
général les championnats du monde
championnat d'Europe en gros c'est un
truc purement commercial ils sont très
contents plus plus on est fou
exactement voilà donc je sais pas après
je pense que quand même bien le mettre
un truc un peu égal à tout le monde
c'est vrai que genre
je sais pas un pays comme la France
peut-être un peu plus facilement envoyer
des joueurs qui sont prêts à payer leurs
frais qu'un joueur plus de l'Est tu vois
donc c'est un peu une équitable
exactement mais bon
qui n'est pas
c'est pas juste clairement
pour ça que ta règle de du champion du
monde qui enfin du champion de France
qui va peut-être cette pas si mal mais
je sais pas comment c'est en Europe des
quatre France et monte seulement deux et
un seul prix en charge
d'accord ok allons sur Cannes 4 4 France
4 meilleur à ne représentants il y a
quand même eu beaucoup de titres l'année
dernière donc ça ça va bien là
on va commencer
alors peut-être est-ce qu'il commence en
décaler
on a eu on a eu moins de 8 - 10 on a eu
deux titres cette année de champion du
monde donc c'est quand même assez
prometteur pour les années qui arrivent
on verra bon les Indiens
ça étonnant d'avoir des titres en moins
de 8 et -10 moi j'aurais imaginé que les
indiens mais ça veut dire la génération
est vraiment traiter onctueuse
parce que
les Indiens sont partout en fait et bon
les Russes sont toujours là mais c'est
vrai que que on voit les Indiens qui
arrivent vraiment très grande force là
dans ces dans tout ce championnat et
aux échecs et puis
tu peux dire tout ce que tu veux au bout
d'un moment il y a la loi du nombre
enfin tu vois voilà comment vas-tu quand
il valise On peut pas à long terme on
peut pas rivaliser avec les Indiens
c'est sûr que si il forme ils ont plus
de formes ils ont plus de monde à former
voilà il y a plus de chance d'avoir des
bons joueurs alors après il t'as des tu
as des ovnis comme manus Carlson voilà
c'est pas du tout un pays d'échec la
Norvège quand il a commencé voilà ça
arrive mais c'est pas pour ça que la
Norvège gagne des Olympiades non la
Norvège est même
même en général pas très bien classé aux
Olympiades donc voilà
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe là on a
toujours pas les parties c'est ce que
c'est normal
malheureusement j'ai pas de news je vais
essayer de lire
[Musique]
non j'ai pas de message
qui gagne qui gagne ah oui une pièce
d'accord et Maxime qui joue le tournoi
aussi c'est bien fait contre Yann et
premiers justement il a fait nul
aujourd'hui contre Douda c'est à dire
qu'il a 50% Maxime et bien c'est pas mal
pour un retour à la campette et on va
certainement avoir les raisins qui va
l'emporter face à des pomyachi là il est
archi gagnant les raisins qui va
rattraper
le groupe de tête qui est composé d'un
seul joueur de Fabiano Carola donc il va
être ils vont être deux joueurs à quatre
et demi sur 7 à de rendre de la fin ils
sont chauds
une belle forme en ce moment et qui a
fait gagner contre les raisins mais
aliasa bien défendu il y a eu
donc intéressant tout ça et ça fait
toujours plaisir ça fait un moment qu'on
n'avait pas vu à les raisins et c'est
vrai qu'à lire Elsa
c'est vrai qu'il Raisa il est quand même
ça fait plaisir de voir jouer il se
chauffe sur les sur les tournois de chez
som il joue ses play-in il se qualifie
et voilà ça lui sert aussi c'est sûr
c'est ton rassurer un peu un peu déçu de
de pas le voir jouer rapidement
[Musique]
c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il faut
oui c'est pas de bêtises oui mais après
il va jouer d'autres des rapides le
concept c'est qu'ils les joues pas tous
ah ils vont tous tourner
rapide
ta Magnus qui joue oui j'ai vu
ça va ça va il a un petit c'est pas volé
un petit palmarès
donc oui
je vérifiais sur un autre twitch
est-ce que sur un autre twitch
et bien normal
qui est très très intéressant par aliasa
et voilà la nouvelle star
c'est les finales moi je sais pas moi je
trouve qu'il est très complet à lire les
raisins oui oui
ça y est le français
il comprend tout et bon peu timide pour
parler mais ça commence à venir
ça viendra ça commence à venir donc
c'est bien
et puis il a dit que
j'adorais ça c'est quand même le tampon
tu vois le tampon France quand tu dis il
a battu Ding et on lui dit tu avais pas
battu champion il est plus facile et
puis il s'est rendu compte du truc il
avait dit et donc il a dit non mais
c'est reste donc
champion du monde plus facile que Magnus
qui est vrai mais voilà là l'arrogance
après la victoire ça c'est c'est la fin
bienvenue on est ravi ça y est
ça y est le tampon définitif est mis là
c'est vraiment
on va s'amuser attaque nucléaire fin du
monde ah bah oui ça c'est une
possibilité sur en fait ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va pas trop y penser
parce que sinon on est mal barré puis si
ça arrive toute façon
elle est pas bien
après c'est pas
bizarre cette histoire il y a un truc je
sais pas est-ce que les infos sur le
slack ou pas
non moi j'ai rien
sur cela que les joueurs ils ont l'air
d'attendre quelque chose
je sais pas nous ce qui peut se passer
je dis oui
je pense que tu es encore des droits que
j'ai pas quoi incroyable
moi j'ai pas tous ces
stars en fait
moi je suis sur j'ai sur deux canaux là
et ça se passe rien
ah ok
ouais c'est possible
donc ouais
voilà on va voir en tout cas on vous
tient au jus par un litre et ça il est
en train de gagner
fait plaisir il va passer enfin je veux
dire je vais dire il va passer le numéro
de mondial mais en fait il est il est
déjà c'est ça qui est beau numéro 2
mondial il est repassé
et on verra il parle français il a une
petite amie jacquenne Garne mais bon si
je savais je te le dirai pas mais je
sais pas
des joueurs à la vie privée les affaires
privées c'est en privé
on sait pas ouais je sais pas oui il a
une petite amie déjà
peut-être un petit ami on sait pas non
déjà voilà
ta question elle est elle est mauvaise
elle a tellement de niveau
Jacqueline
alors on voit les joueurs qui sont
toujours en train d'attendre peut-être
en léger problème technique de la part
de
temps en temps
c'est pas
impossible mais les joueurs qui sont en
stand-by
on va voir
mais en tout cas rester parce que ce
match là va être passionnant on va le
suivre et en plus on a ikabora à la star
du stream
qui est derrière 18h ou 18h30
et ça a commencé attends je vais
remettre les caméras parce que je vais
faire je suis en train de faire quelque
chose
et on va les parties qui qui
chez moi en tout cas a commencé à partir
de Prague contre
[Musique]
il y a 7,5 pour les Chinois donc il faut
au moins marquer plus de pour les
Indiens donc au moins trois quoi
donc 6 ampères plus que 1 et demi mais
c'est terminé ce sera gain qualification
en finale pour pour les Chinois
alors ce système de Londres ouais
tranquille solide
et on l'a vu au match championnat du
monde c'était quand même une surprise
c'est très bien passé d'ailleurs pour le
blanc
dans une très belle partie
donc système de Londres même quand on
sait que ça peut arriver c'est pas
évident avec les Noirs
les plus agressifs de la part de VI qui
change pas sa façon de jouer en fonction
du en fonction du score ça c'est ouf
parce que quand même ça a souvent envie
de prendre en compte le résultat là tu
as plus de dis bon ok nul c'est pas mal
tu vois en plus tu as les noirs
mais il joue après
ça a du sens
sûrement avoir un
petit roc petit roc
ensuite je sais pas comment ça se
positionner
le Top 16 est-ce que je sais pas le Top
tous viennent nous dire qu'il va
peut-être suivre les dernières parties
alors le début
je crois de jour ou trois jours enfin je
crois que il y a moyen de de regarder en
tout cas à la fin du Top 16 dans les
dans les poules hautes pull basses bon
je sais pas du tout si ça va se faire
j'en sais rien du tout
tu sais déjà à qui tu commentes
d'envoyer ou
alors ça va changer on m'a dit des trucs
mais
j'ai plusieurs non je sais pas
que je vais bientôt commencer à bientôt
et je crois que je serai avec Libye
et pas que mais je sais plus je sais
plus mais la voiture ça apparemment
c'était pas sur encore ça
quand le concours
donc
on verra
c'était pas clair encore
des infos tu fais de l'imbécile toi
alors peut-être pour toi oui contre toi
je te fais de la B6 vas-y on joue ça
c'est le coup le plus chaud
c'est moi je m'attendais à ça plutôt de
la part de mes pots d'imbécis puis on
prend ces cinq dame prend B2 c'est la
balance la plus chaude
et donc très très concret en général
évidemment c'est noir France savent ce
qu'ils font ça tient
mais hyper compliqué
et bien aussi une variante très connue
très à la mode et
très intéressant
ok donc là il y a quand même peur de fou
pour les noirs
et puis en plus quand même pour les
blancs
ici en C5
comment on continue
je sais pas ce qu'on fait dame C7
peut-être pour un marché
je vais essayer de jouer B4 quoi un
cavalent des cartes comme ça
est-ce qu'on fait un petit rapide tour
des stats peut-être parce qu'elle est
tellement importante avec sourcil ou
Souilly enfin ça vai shaili twei qui est
quand même à 3 sur 3 une master class
aujourd'hui
normalement la joueuse sur le papier la
plus faible
qui va continuer son juste pour voir un
petit peu le début de partie je vous
mets la
je peux pas mettre le comme le cleescom
là l'avancée enfin les coups qui
avancent automatiquement je dois le
faire moi-même
ok cavaler les quatre donc ça c'est où
j'ai dit cela
c'est pas normal ça
peut-être toi non tu dois connaître
si si c'est pas normal mais c'est une
ligne
c'est un peu normalement c'est censé
être douteux mais bon
on donne la part de fou mais on a quand
même accès à la case des 5 avis
maintenant exactement
un peu bizarre
et du coup l'hôpital a été mangé
donc il y a quand même inventé
du F5 qui peut arriver les cases noires
sont potentiellement faibles aussi c'est
pas c'est pas si clair je masse grands
en fait
c'est la partie
texto
c'est vite cahier
menace vous prend et cavaliers
et maintenant
comment on fait
je pense que je suis obligé de jouer B5
ou B3 F5 c'est le c'est mon premier
réflexe en tout cas mais bon je suis pas
très bon c'est position dynamique
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire sinon F5
pour menacer du faux 5 j'ai peut-être
même grand
rock là
je crois que je gagne
je peux prendre je prends le 7 je pense
et je prends un décès et comme ça je
gagne un tempo sur le cavalière recette
ça a l'air complètement gagnant pour les
blancs
ok donc ouais encore c'est chaud c'est
pas concret
le plus grand pêcheur que je connaisse
[Rires]
Kevin notre ami de Pro Évolution échec
avec sa belle épée de
je disais rien parce qu'il est assez
agréable dès que je salue je
fais plus j'ai arrêté
un petit truc
intéressant
[Rires]
une excellente excellente remarque mais
depuis que des petits capteurs m'ont dit
m'ont envoyé le clip je voulais envoyer
hein
apparemment ah bon
[Musique]
franchement
merde
ou pas non non
[Musique]
il a fait
récupéré comme ça
qui est toujours une faiblesse
et quand tu prends C3 billet prend ta
nouvelle structure mais tu as qu'à me
frapper derrière et l'option bah il est
là quoi mais oui mais attends
c'est la partie on va voir ouais mais
bon qu'est-ce que tu veux faire en fait
il faut récupérer le pion quand même
mais j'ai l'impression que la mort c'est
quand même assez facile il y a plein de
pions sur case blanche qui me font un
petit peu peur
même par exemple le simple coup
peut-être sur la prise en 4 tours
le roi va venir ici le fou il est
monstrueux en B3 c'est une super pièce
un fou tape sur l'option sur le roi G8
je réponds
tu peux tu peux
un petit cœur je te mets un petit cœur
Kevin alors au Top 16 mais bien oui
alors est-ce que est-ce que vous allez
vous fixer un échiquier quand même mais
bien sûr
comme d'habitude
depuis 2009
2009 alors
2009 c'est à dire 2009
et j'étais sa plus grosse défaite ever
apparemment je suis toujours là j'avais
[Rires]
tout le monde a envie de jouer au top
c'est Kévin ça fait quoi en fait d'être
le foot
c'est quand même non on se pose des
questions comment ça comment ça marche
pas très facile à vivre cette histoire
alors est-ce qu'il a une chance
au cas où un roi en B2
j'avais peur on va peut-être le mettre
en B2
un des deux pour échanger une paire de
Tours et après tu as quand même
qui sont assez faibles parce qu'ils sont
avancés ils sont prenables et même sur
un truc comme ça bah franchement tour
des deux alors quand même pas mal parce
qu'au final après l'échange des tours
pas mon roi elle est quand même beaucoup
plus actif que le tien et ce pion ainsi
s'il va il va tomber enfin l'impression
que je vais aller le manger
[Musique]
par la tour bah après je monte mon roi
etc donc il y a peut-être du tout recat
bon c'est à voir mais c'est vrai que les
Blancs alors quand même pas mal du tout
ici et donc peut-être que du coup la
place de tour C8 faire tourner 6
ici et blindé mais c'est passif
peut-être ça et ça en fait au final et
ça peut-être que ça peut c'est quoi la
partie
[Musique]
attention il pousse hein qui gagne ça
fait 8,5 et c'est quasiment 40 elle est
importante cette partie
nul
ok c'est pas mal pour les Chinois cette
ennemi 5 et demi on va voir d'autres
parties
trois demi sur 4 un très très beau score
de la part de couilles
alors tu veux voir qui maintenant
alors Prague c'est attends je vais
peut-être faire la fenêtre excuse-moi
quand mes cloche
donc il est 18h c'est presque ma caméra
tu vois même chez moi là où j'habite
pas
alors est-ce qu'on a on a un pure moins
mais on a des des décompenses quand même
avec ces pions A et B se fout en G7 on
peut menacer B4 et puis en B2 va être
faible
ça ressemble à des compensations une
nulle évidemment chaque nul est très
très positive pour les pour les Chinois
un peu mais la partie de
freinage ça se dirige quand même vers
une même alors là maintenant il y a eu
un échange 5
il y a aucun risque avec les blancs mais
je ne sais pas
mais en fait juste pour dire que il y a
quelques coups c'était il a changé de
cavaliers je sais pas trop est-ce que ça
doit venir une chance au moins parce que
si ça doit nier aussi mal bon ben laisse
tomber hein
passer mobile
tu veux voir
quoi je te laisse choisir tu es mon
invité
moi j'aime bien celle-là
ok allez comme ça on vibreur
[Rires]
après si tu veux voir un truc n'hésite
pas
le match peut être terminé pas sous nos
yeux dès qu'il y a un point pour le
chinois mais ça on y peut rien en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que ça doit ni
doit gagner c'est la seule belle
position
donc bon il faut absolument qu'il gagne
pour entretenir l'espoir d'un éventuel
tie break pour les Indiens
qu'il est hyper bien avec les Blancs il
y a quand même des chances de gains avec
la majorité au centre le pion arriverait
en C5 etc mais tu vois aussi la finale
contre Prague ou à la à la elle a réussi
à hyper bien défendre donc tu dis que ok
c'est elle est capable c'est pas si
clair
et donc H3 donc j'ai 4 on veut être un
pouce un peu les pions ouvrir des
colonnes et cetera
et est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'il y a
moyen de
de
voir un peu le reste
qui va arriver
qui est défend formidablement bien et
qui a fait un peu le tournant de ce
match en battant pragamanda c'était
vraiment le point d'avance là qu'ils ont
en fait si il prend un a gagné c'était
le match serait complètement égalité
maintenant mais à la battu prend un
endroit qui a pris trop de risques dans
cette finale
c'est dur c'est très très dur ici
je fais un petit salut amical à nos amis
de Youtube c'est quoi la demi-finale
c'est les Gotham chess avec
icarbonakamura contre j'ai oublié je
crois que c'est une autre équipe
américaine
le bracket si tu veux voir il est prêt
donc MGD 1 c'est ah non c'est indien
donc ça va être encore une fois un
super match
les parties
donc on a encore deux équipes indiennes
en lice
4G 4 fini tu peux rien faire avec les
Noirs
tu as l'impression que
le pion c'est il compte pas et puis on
débloquer quoi et puis le cavalier toi
rester à la défense depuis sa douanier a
gagné allez c'était mis on va voir Louis
ping
et ça a l'air un peu de s'échanger ça
poussette ça poussette mais bon
quand même avec les Blancs
[Musique]
quelque part OK
donc il y a un pion de plus qu'un le
pion est là mais le Caval est pas stable
ici
voir si vraiment il y a moyen de tenir
tenir ce pion mais ça m'a l'air pas très
naturel tu vois je pense que à un moment
donné ce pion il va tomber
je sais pas comment peut-être un jour un
fou des quatre tu commences par roi G7
voilà ouais il a plein de temps en plus
de 30 secondes
ça va faire nul allez et surtout sur
pramech alors prenez ce qui va devoir
gagner avec les Noirs alors attends je
vais mettre quand même le côté blanc
parce que
alors c'est mieux tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il fait tomber si il a bien raison
donc bon
iPad on sait on sait jamais
on sait jamais un gros doigt peu vite
moi j'aurais peur peut-être qu'il s'est
fait voler son ordinateur c'est pas
c'est marrant j'ai l'impression que ils
sont tous dans les hôtels les Chinois
voilà c'est là ouais mais je pense que
c'est leur
parce que je m'étais déjà fait la même
réflexion avec
avec Ding ou je sais plus avec qui mais
je crois que c'est Ding ouais lors du
speechess tu as l'impression qu'il est à
l'hôtel en fait
je pense qu'il vit dans un hôtel ou que
il a transformé sa maison l'hôtel ou ou
il aime bien le décor de l'hôtel mais en
tout cas bon les noirs qui s'activent
quand même il tente le coup clairement
qui peut arriver alors pour ces trois
que tu avais donné
une stratégie qui pourrait être pas si
mal sachant que on a vu que
Louis pink était pas forcément si bon
que ça en diagonale ce serait essayer de
les petits coups et de faire réfléchir
et gagner un petit peu de temps la
pendule pour
[Musique]
des bons là il y a pas grand chose à
faire
pas grand chose à faire
si il fait nul c'est quasiment fini en
fait c'est quasiment
c'est ça
plus fragile que veille donc il faut il
faut jouer celle-là même si évidemment
bon il y a objectivement aucune chance
de la jouer pour la gagner ça c'est sûr
ça doit ni contre joanzone il a mangé la
pièce et Prague alors est-ce qu'il a
fait un miracle contre
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est même moins bien je
pense que c'est la Tour Eiffel je pense
qu'il officiellement bien en fait par
exemple
je sais pas
il a trois secondes trois secondes pour
c'est vrai que c'est dur je pense que je
pense que les Chinois qui vont en finale
ouais
c'est quasiment clair tandis que
breaking news dans le toit de Bucarest
je vous ai dit toujours guéri abattu le
champion du monde
donc belle victoire d'anis guérit tandis
que Ali Reza c'est peut-être compliqué
un peu il y a peut-être une forteresse
c'est marrant on ira faire un tour je
sais pas si gagnant ça ou pas
probablement mais c'est pas sûr à 100%
alors Prague voyez donc là maintenant on
est on est avec gain obligatoire des
blancs
et je te dis hein je pense que Prague
est devenu une petite moins bien
ce petit pion en les chinois ils ont
bien compris que ce pion il va toujours
ici
et il y a un problème sur le F2 sur le
pion à deux
il a tenté qu'un second pour veiller ça
peut être chaud ça peut être une une
déco une gaffe on sait pas ce qui peut
se passer je vois le sang qui tente de
tout pour le tout
attention attention fourchette là bon il
y a pas de fourchette encore mais ça
pourrait arriver un jour attention aussi
aux cavaliers qui peut être dominé par
le four plein de cas un F5
attention
il y a pas d'opposition à cause du Fou
et
mais bon ok là c'est sûr que
donc ça veut dire
a gagné et donc je traque gagne ça avec
les Blancs pour pour
se qualifier pour le départage mais on
n'aura pas de départage dans ce match
Prague ne pourra pas gagner cette partie
c'est juste avant une déconnexion roi F3
j'ai encore cavale de 5 en mode
déconnexion à moins de de une très très
vilaine faute de souris je vois pas du
tout comment
et là le cavalier qui est perdu hein
cavalier 6 cavalier là voilà le cavalier
est perdu
et bravo qui font qui font un match
assez incroyable avec d'ailleurs tu l'as
dit tout à l'heure Djoudi qui fait non
c'est oui c'est lui qui fait 3 et demi
sur 4 en étant le numéro 3 de l'équipe
donc c'est c'est assez impressionnant et
donc ils vont jouer en finale à contre
l'équipe gagnante de ce qu'on va voir
dans un instant avec l'équipe de
Nakamura contre l'équipe de de erégasi
donc
un gros gros match à suivre qui commence
il me semble bien à 18h30 Laurent je
passe à des infos ou 18h
dans un des 18 canaux ou tu n'es pas sur
slack pour voir ouais
un truc
[Musique]
parce que je
on fait on fait une petite pause on
essaie de voir une abeille
pour le prochain match on fait une pause
parce qu'elle est passionnante cette
finale
et puis on revient pour pour vous dire
un peu ce qui se passe à quelle heure ça
commence on ira voir un petit peu aux
gens etc et donc voilà à tout de suite
attends je me suis perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour à tomates qui
vient de commencer avec
icarbonate noir dans cette partie face à
Arika donc à Rica c'est une des
meilleures jauge au monde aussi une
chose indienne avec 2500 et quelques
kilos alors je vais juste une petite
seconde je vais présenter rapidement les
équipes pendant que tu fais les petits
réglages on a hikaruna kamura chez les
gothams qu'on présente encore IKA ou un
des meilleurs joueurs online
au monde numéro 5 mondial même en partie
classique donc c'est pas simplement
une légende du jeu
ensuite on a Vladimir phéno CF donc très
beau duo d'attaquant fait de CIF très
très gros joueur en rapide qui était
même Vich champion du monde de partir
rapide imaginez-vous ensuite on a vos
rideaux vous variedov je vois pas très
bien
est-ce que c'est notre ami est-ce que
c'est le grand maître champion olympique
avec oui
je crois qu'il fait partie de l'équipe
olympique ah ouais Dieu qui peut
l'Olympique ouzbek qui a été champion
d'Olympique bon voilà je crois que je
crois que c'est clair hein gros grosse
équipe et en dernier je la connais pas
mais ils ont dû recruter une jeune qui
est en train de progresser
c'est en général ce que font les grandes
équipes tandiska en face on a donc Arica
comme tu le disais ensuite est-ce que ça
serait pas c'est gauche ensuite gauche
qu'on avait on avait découvert ici
ensuite
qui est très intéressant
et ensuite bon bah des meilleurs joueurs
au monde donc de très belles équipes ah
je dirais quand même a priori un
avantage quand même
à Gotham Knight ça dépend un peu de leur
féminine je sais pas aloi normanova je
connais pas du tout son niveau très
honnêtement mais à mon avis il faut pas
les choses au hasard les Américains donc
c'est bien possible que ça soit vraiment
une des meilleures choses au monde et on
voit et car on a qu'à moi qui parle à un
instrument en même temps
c'est parti en direct c'est de la pub
vous le voyez pas encore
pardon pardon pardon pardon vous allez
le voir il stream en même temps
incroyable
et salut à tous qui nous ce qui nous
rejoignent creative minds salut à toi
merci
je la connais bien
et vous avez du coup la partie donc là
il y a la caméra qui sont mises le temps
il est pas très bien mis à jouer c'est
de vous remettre ça bien aussi tout a
bougé depuis que le match c'est terminé
donc il a pas l'air très très enfin il
fait un peu la grimace comme comme ça
expliqué les ouvertures c'est compliqué
il y a énormément de théories là comme
ça en 5 minutes c'est toujours très
compliqué
le centre etc mais ça il y a beaucoup de
matériel sur cheescom donc n'hésitez pas
à aller voir le matériel aussi online
vous pouvez trouver énormément de choses
allez voir notre ami pour évolution
échec qui avait une interview aussi qui
fait de très belles choses qui peut
expliquer les ouvertures avec là bon en
fait les ouvertures dans ce genre de de
format partie rapide sont pas décisives
alors c'est important évidemment mais
c'est pas décisif
et justement je dis ça mais Nakamura il
est très très bien après l'ouverture et
il a déjà un pion de plus en E3
sans que aujourd'hui il va faire le show
il va essayer de tout gagner là c'est
une première petite finale parce que
cette enfin ce match qualifiera pour
pour la grande finale contre les Chinois
les Chinois les
Tigers
hyper impressionnant contre l'équipe
amenée par par Prague c'était vraiment
vraiment monstrueux donc en tout cas là
en disant encore un indien là tu vois
c'est marrant que que les Chinois
rejouent contre les Indiens tu vois ça
serait marrant de travailler comme ça
mais il a fait j'ai 5 attention moi je
pense que les
j'aimerais bien voir comment joue
normanova ça sera peut-être intéressant
d'aller la voir quand d'ailleurs contre
iriga easy ça sera clé si elle joue bien
si elle fait des points bon je vois pas
comment ils peuvent s'en sortir les
Indiens alors moi je vois qu'elle a 2083
et l'autre sur son sur cheesecom je peux
aller voir si tu veux à côté
c'est pas terrible pour quelqu'un qui
joue la demi-finale de la prochaine
League oui mais je vais regarder attends
[Musique]
on avait déjà vu en plus je crois à 2118
elle est née en 2016
ah oui et elle vient de perdre 150
points en deux en deux classement
d'accord donc elle était elle était à 22
et elle a perdu 50 points puissant point
mais bon c'est c'est coefficient 40 donc
en fait on sait pas trop trop tu vois
c'est ça peut c'est pas très très
significatif encore elle est jeune
et
donc elle fait des points en tout cas
elle doit
gentille à loi
je suis un peu fatigué
tourger 5 sur mon tour 3 va être joué
dans trois B4
oui très bien vu
toute façon
en fait j'ai l'impression que que je
perds je perds je perds ici maintenant
c'est la partie étrange en fait
peut-être manger ces trois F7 peut-être
je fouette
comme tu l'as dit j'ai cette qui va
arriver bon ça paraît ça paraît cuit ça
paraît trop dur
pour Aika oui bah c'est
effectivement
c'est ça a l'air trop dur
quand même mais
c'est vrai
mais il est capable de toute façon on
connaît on connaît les arguments mais
non
on va voir on change de partout on fait
un petit tour donc là on a gauche contre
fedo segave je vais mettre des caméras
alors dans un instant
alors
fedo Cie
j'ai pas fait mes devoirs là j'ai pas
réglé
ça lors de cette première ronde fedo qui
allait blanc qu'elle est noir pardon
contre gauche
donc depayan c'est encore un jeune
Indien et dans la voyait qu'il est la
caméra qui est à l'envers et on voit
c'est pas la bonne
ils ont tous deux caméras une par
derrière pour pouvoir être sûr que ben
on triche pas on essaie de voir un peu
ce qui se passe donc là vous voyez un
peu chez lui
on va quand même voir la vraie caméra de
lui
elle est là bon on va on va un peu moins
bien mais on voit ses yeux et
donc donc voilà il y a des blancs il a
quel âge
tu sais un petit peu parce que tu
connais un peu le genre pas du tout
finalement le vétéran
Ie
ça fait combien d'années qu'il faut j'ai
l'impression que quand j'étais pané
était déjà au top oh non non non non non
alors gauche il est né en 98
donc il a 31 ans
qu'il est très fort et ça fait longtemps
que ce nom il est connu tu vois et c'est
vrai que
pour moi c'était un joueur qui avait
déjà
alors E4 jouer pour déstabiliser ce fou
en C4 et ouvrir les lignes avec notre
qualité en plus et bien écoute ça a
l'air d'être très bien joué de la part
de gauche on joue sur le fait que le fou
soit en prise ici aussi
que 4 peut pas trop manger parce qu'il y
a trois C4
compliqué c'est compliqué mais j'aime
bien les blancs quand même
vis-à-vis fou d'âme ça fait peur même
sans calculer tu sens que des problèmes
chez les Noirs c'est vrai après
heureusement pour les Noirs il y a cette
case des cinq stables pour le cavalier
voilà tu prends des sacs heureusement
sinon ça serait ça serait juste perdant
faut prendre cavalier prend et je suis
très solide quand même sur mes appuis
mais si j'avais pas cette case de 5
comme je disais c'était juste qu'elle
était plus
ok si tu veux voir un peu bah du coup
je suis curieux de découvrir notre ami
normanova il est là je vais vous mettre
les caméras
donc il a les noirs
et il rage et pas pris la bonne caméra
et au mois de 20 je vais vous la mettre
ici
donc toujours avec ce truc de dos
je crois qu'elle était jeune
2007 ça fait pas 25 là tu t'égares au
début
tout à l'heure
2007 elle a 25 ans
ça va être compliqué les comptes
non et là elle a 15 ans
et oui ça a l'air d'être ça
il est où il est où
et sous classé apparemment vu qu'elle a
perdu pas mal de points mais bon contre
en tout cas on voit que elle a 2100
hello mais elle avait 22 70
il y a deux mois
mais bon 140 c'est jeune et ouais bien
sûr
mais on sait qu'elle est entre 21 22
quoi ça c'est
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut en tout cas
voir donc en fait je sais pas moi j'ai
envie de dire que l'équipe de Naka est
favorite et apparemment que l'équipe des
Indiens est favorite
ah ben non je pense que je crois
non je trouve que la
joueur Naka esthétocs sont quand même au
dessus vos rideau je pense qu'il est bon
rideau je vais voir si c'est celui qui a
gagné c'est celui qui a gagné dans la
piades ah oui c'est le sujet d'accord
allez
ok
ils sont hyper bon mais au 4 il risque
de faire zéro donc en fait
si tu fais 0 ça veut dire que ça que les
Indiens commencent à la 4 points ouais
mais Erika il va pas faire le
c'est vrai qu'avec un
on en discute mais c'est c'est pas si
clair
c'est pas
je pense que
Gotham et
assez facile
maintenant c'est facile
tu es quand même bien
habitués à faire des super résultats sur
Internet comme facebook
[Musique]
on parlait la forme des joueurs il faut
pas se rater parce que là ils comptent
sur toi et en fait
je pense que à l'oie
quand même si elle fait pas zéro c'est
un exploit parce qu'en face elle a
vraiment des super super joueur
et alors que tes trois joueurs à toi ben
écoute bon ok Carlos est quasiment du
sucre quoi mais derrière il faut être en
forme quand même
et c'était en forme je suis d'accord que
c'est un équipe de ouf
mais sinon il faut remarquer des points
quoi
[Musique]
c'est pas africain
les Gotham Knights qui entre guillemets
sacrifie le 4e chiqué pour mettre des
gens beaucoup plus forts
enfin
moins que elle a l'air de jouer ouais
non là elle se fait elle se fait raser
mais c'est pas si
oui si quand même si c'est difficile à
axé puis on sent trop là E5 V4 là qui
pousse
[Musique]
qui va il va mettre son point
ça c'est pas c'est pas une surprise
importante en fait que deux joueurs
mais
encore pris la mauvaise [__] j'avais
une chance sur deux à chaque fois quoi
c'est un truc de fou quand même
je vais vous changer la le
mettre de face quand même ça sera mieux
que de voir la belle tapisserie de sa
chambre
[Rires]
il est là il est bien alors il est où
il est là
Hannibal
c'est bien ça
mais il est bien
ok donc c'est comme ça et
trois quatre cinq trois quatre cinq six
c'est un pion de plus pour les Noirs
mais la tour en 17 qui va peut-être ou
pas ou pas
donc il faut que j'arrive à anticiper
pour pas qu'il donne P3 mais la perte C7
il risque de perdre cette [__] aussi
parce qu'un retour
donc certes les lois du mal à bouger ça
c'est super là tu bouges la tour
il y a du jeu c'est pas un pion gratos
mais depuis on se calme depuis
savoir comment tu veux perdre ce pion en
quelles conditions
tu peux je cisque c'est mètre carré en
dessin
et moi peu importe
j'ai fait une prendre la seule de la
position c'est la fourchette c'est 4
ouais mais si tu me laisses les deux
pions passés liés
par les noirs
de 5 c'est un bon coup pratique j'aime
bien
est-ce qu'il va faire cavalier 5 sur ça
il s'en sort
ok
rien faire
chez les Blancs
aussi
et c'est 6
c'est un peu passif mais l'option et là
toujours
toujours dans l'idée même tout au 4 et
pas débile
enfin un tatouage
je peux vraiment prendre de l'espace
essayer de passer ouais mais c'est pas
si clair là parce que une fois que le
roi est en D7 ouais je peux ça libère ma
tour en fait
je pense qu'il faut pas que je te laisse
aussi facilement mais moi peut-être je
peux pas faire grand chose en tout cas
il fait il fait ses 6
je joue comme cette finale là qui est
quand même bien pour les Noirs c'est un
pion de plus quand même
donc voilà techniquement au fur et à
mesure peut-être que je peux essayer de
prendre un avantage juste ici ça
construit un peu mais
ok les blancs veulent changer les pions
un moyen de pion plus ils sont venus le
H5 tours F14
de perdre après
mais en fait peut-être quand même il
faut calculer
il y a 40 secondes
pour prendre une grosse décision là mais
oui il y a 5 est tellement avantageux
pour les noirs pour les blancs si on
arrive à échanger
en plus c'est que l'échange disons que
la nulle commence à être
envisageable quoi mais si tu arrives pas
à les changer c'est que ce pion va être
faible tu vois peut-être non ça ça par
exemple
un truc comme ça va être faible mais bon
la finale de la finale de roi elle donne
quoi
après tout F5
[Musique]
était plus utile clairement mais bon
c'est pas facile de
de prendre ses décisions avec peu de
temps ce qui me responsable
c'est la ronde un bon
je sais pas
on n'a pas de résultats je peux
peut-être vous dire s'il y a des trucs
on va finir qui est en train de
la perdre
pardon ah non pardon il a il a deux
pièces
j'ai mal compris
en tout cas dans cette première partie
voilà c'est Dame de plus simple
on voit que
erégasi a gagné aussi donc on va
repartir de coucher Rocky
cette partie là elle est importante pour
les indiens pour essayer de garder
contact
énormément de points en journée ouais
c'est possible c'est pour ça que j'ai un
peu peur pour les Indiens
après
beaucoup de parties mais il peut aussi
il peut aussi faire quatre
c'est sûr c'est un joueur qui peut
qui peut la colonne aka qui peut la
coller à fedo
et dans un bonjour non c'est un match
vraiment pas clair
je reste fidèle évidemment
donc tu peux pas bouger en fait
mais bon il s'est mis dans une situation
difficile quand même vorridoff un peu
mais ça va ouais toujours très sérieux
un joueur joueur de l'équipe olympique
championne donc ils avaient quand même
et quand même pas mal il est habitué à
jouer avec de l'enjeu bon Hannibal comme
tu l'as dit même s'il est plus jeune que
ce que tu imaginais il a quand même
aussi l'habitude de l'expérience des
gros tournois
donc les deux joueurs qui sont habitués
à jouer ce genre de match très très
important
puis là en fait même si la position elle
est peut-être nulle mais en équipe tu es
obligé de la jouer et puis en plus tu
sais que tu as zéro chance de perdre
donc en fait si jamais d'ailleurs
attends peut-être que tu peux jouer un
roi des saints qui roi étoile F4 voilà
tu peux plus le droit des cinq mais dans
l'idée de F4 ça peut être pas mal c'est
34 comprend ou alors les tours J5
mais dans les débats les Noirs ont zéro
chance de perdre donc il faut il faut
tenter
ou F4 ou la F4 ça fait mal
5 si on reprend ses quatre pions 5
maintenant et on avance
mieux les blancs sont mieux
à trop pousser là il a pas vu F4 F4
était un super courroie des 5 attention
E6 oui pour faire dam OK et c'est une
gaffe apparemment j'ai le pion quand
même tant qu'à faire
c'est vrai
maintenant est-ce que tu es est-ce que
tu es à l'heure là c'est chaud là aussi
fini c'est fini non non mais
l'ordi ou j'ai 5 secondes
ah c'est ouf ah ça va faire Damme et H2
attaque touche la tour oh le bol ça
c'est un peu de chat quand même
logique
et là maintenant il ramasse plus la tour
c'est gagnant apparemment d'après la
jauge incroyable
il faut pas se faire prendre la tour ni
la dame
ça va être fini
il a bien raison
c'est fini
c'est malin ce qu'il a fait son truc de
tout reprendre H2 là regarde la tour
[Musique]
il se défend pas mal quoi non non mais
c'est clair
mais en tout cas bon c'est tu vois c'est
bien parce que c'est jeune là qui sont
capables vraiment de tout et qui se
battent vraiment jusqu'au bout et c'est
vrai que c'était
de la carte qui gagne déjà trois en
premier set ça fait peur je l'ai dit il
y a pas de 4e 7 dans ce match
pour pour la deuxième partie je vais
même prendre les apparents là je vais
vous donner un si vous voulez en même
temps que je l'aimais très probablement
gauche
tandis que faiso CF sera opposé à
Rica je crois alors n'a qu'à blanc
contre gauche
où est-il monsieur Nakamura il est là
avec les Blancs cette fois-ci on va
mettre en bas 4 1
fais aussi
blanc contre en même temps
chevronné
n'hésite pas
deuxième ça va faire un petit fait
dossier contre Arica comme annoncer
sa caméra mais ça il le fait tout le
temps
quand il est pas en stream
[Musique]
il aura les blancs
mais qui a eu aucune chance contre
Hikaru là qui allait en forme là comme
d'hab ça sent les Caroline
[Musique]
une belle vision du jeu et pendant ce
temps ouais c'est ce que je pensais la
finale de il y a pas de forteresse chez
des pomyachi Ali resafiruja gagne sa
partie face à des pomyachi et rejoins le
leader
Fabienne ocarwana et il passe je vais
vous le dire combien en vélo il passe à
2792,6 soit numéro 2 mondial
et à
277,77,4 et Nakamura 5e jour mondiale
775 Nakamura qui pourrait passer au
numéro 3 mondial finalement sans jouer
c'est ils sont une des fêtes de lui
passer derrière donc très très belle
opération pour aller résafiruja et pour
Fabiana qui revient numéro 6 mondial
avec 2773,1
2771,2 pour Aniche guéri qui vient de
battre le champion du monde
en titre Maxime il en est où ouais
Maxime gagne quelques points
à la 13e place mondiale un rank est
quand même plus conforme à son talent
avec 2746,5
ouais c'est gagné tous les joueurs enfin
beaucoup de joueurs en tout cas du top
niveau perte des points hello quand même
que
la masse générale
10 elle descend quand même parce qu'il y
avait une époque tu avais quand même
plusieurs argent en fait même deux trois
plus de 2008 et pas mal à 90 85 tu vois
et là j'ai l'impression que maintenant
le top bah en fait ils sont tous à 50 60
[Musique]
c'est pas en mai 2011 après je suis
revenu mais
j'étais pas à ce moment-là et simplement
35 joueurs
[Musique]
je sais pas
alors on va bientôt reprendre la
deuxième partie
je suppose
et ouais belle avantage pour écouter
nights qui sont
définitivement
alors effectivement les Indiens ont pas
encore perdu mais
non non
ils ont vraiment une équipe de
mais les deux sont monstrueux parce que
là c'est vrai tu as quand même trois
trois monstres
chez Naka Naka qui est capable de tout
gagner fait d'essayev qui a un gros
pointeur et évoqué d'oeuf qui est gros
talent aussi qui est assez jeune et qui
a quasiment 2006 déjà
c'est ça va être dur en fait
je me trompe peut-être
je me trompe peut-être je te laisse
vérifier
mais bon
oui ce coup de F4 montre qu'il est il
est agile il a de la ressource
clairement et il fait attention à toutes
les ressources et
il peut toujours jouer la gagne
la caille par les stream le bruit est
tellement habitué à le faire mais je
pense que ça lui donne de la force il
avait déjà dit qu'en fait le fait qu'il
sache qu'il y a autant de gens qui le
soutiennent pendant son stream ça lui
donne de la force quoi et et
ils se sent beaucoup plus fort en stream
que hors string c'est marrant
genre en fait c'est ce qualifie si ce
qualifie match champion du monde il va
vouloir streamer en jouant quoi
c'est très bizarre quand tu le vois il
est pas du tout
un vrai vie il est pas du tout comme ça
extraverti mais en fait ouais dès qu'il
est devant la caméra c'est incroyable
c'est la métamorphose
bon tant mieux pour lui
on va voir en tout cas s'il va se
peut-être c'est vrai
tu vas se qualifier au candidat déjà
je pense qu'il va essayer quoi qu'il
joue bientôt il joue le nom de chat
ok ok
je pense qu'il a pas complètement
abandonné l'idée c'est à dire que ce
qu'il faut voir
c'est cette cette défection un petit peu
de Magnus enfin ce refus de
défendre son titre ça doit être l'espoir
pas mal de monde parce que tu te dis
ok je gagne candidats bon les problèmes
j'ai quand même un gros match derrière
tu vois ce que je veux dire là c'est
Ding il paraît plus fragile largement
c'est largement ouvert quoi
du top 10 contre Ding c'est chaud quoi
c'est dur quoi c'est chaud mais
je crois que ça a donné de l'espoir à
une génération finalement
tu sais la génération battue écoeurée
par Carlsen le roi est parti le trône
est alors il est pas libre parce qu'il
est occupé par Ding mais on sent que
c'est
il peut y avoir une petite révolution
interne tu vois
maintenant c'est intéressant quoi
peut-être que maintenant des gens qui
vont se réveiller en fait
au final ça m'intéresse
et donc peut-être un retour sur les
parties classiques avec un petit match à
la clé enfin il faut déjà faut gagner le
candidat c'est pas bien sûr est-ce que
tu penses éventuellement un retour de
cartel dans quelques années
non je crois que ça sera trop tard en
quelques années c'est ça le problème non
mais je sais pas par exemple bon s'il
continue d'ici je sais pas deux trois
championnats du monde
ça fera plus de 35 ans est-ce qu'il sera
toujours moi je crois que Magnus
il nous reste allez 50 Max
comme numéro un mondial
[Musique]
et puis il va il joue moins là
bonjour
si
vous mettez en classique ouais c'est ça
donc il aime pas trop les classiques
donc
est-ce qu'il va vraiment
pense pas je crois qu'il est en général
il est assez fiable sur ce qu'il dit
donc ce qu'il dit c'est que les parties
classiques ça leur nuit c'est vrai que
faut trouver des c'est vrai que les
joueurs contre lui et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on a vu un match intéressant
mais c'est pas de sa faute c'est que les
joueurs contre lui le gros avantage de
ce match d'ingpo c'est qu'il disait les
deux bon ben j'ai ma chance quoi est-ce
que contre Magnus il ferme le jeu c'est
pas du tout le même style de jeu quand
les joueurs jouent jouent Magnus et donc
c'est ce qui a fait un match beaucoup
plus ouvert sur
sur sur ce match d'Astana entre nepo et
digne Skype Magnus c'est vrai que ça
jouait beaucoup plus serré on se
rappelle même le match contre kayakine
bon là c'était
lui il fermait le jeu à fond parce qu'il
avait peur tout simplement il savait
qu'il était moins fort donc il savait
que il fallait que ça faisait des nuls
c'était bien
ouais ouais mais même si parce que il a
il avait dit qu'il éventuellement contre
un virus là bon avant d'arrêter que il
jouerait que contre les gens
sifférusa il des trône
et d'être ending est-ce que ça intéresse
ou est-ce que s'il y a arrive je sais
pas un goût caisse d'ici deux ans ou un
mais en fait on sait je crois que même
lui c'est pas
le problème c'est qu'il verra et en
fonction ouais s'il peut y avoir un
goûté chaud évidemment qu'il aimerait
comme tout le monde il aimerait bien
battre la nouvelle génération la
génération d'après tu vois c'est c'est
le rêve de tous les grands joueurs et
sportif tout ça c'est quand même des
joueurs qu'il a quand même beaucoup
moins joué parce que là tu as un match
contre une époque
ça m'intéresse moins parce que c'est
toujours la même chose en fait ils ont
pas parce que nepo était pas dans le top
en fait il a une ascension assez récente
mais allez-y commence à avoir pas mal de
parties ça se passe très bien pour
l'instant pour Magnus bon ça risque de
changer un moment ou un autre mais
effectivement il aimerait bien un match
contre
les candidats je sais pas
je sais pas on verra
alors ce petit match là donc la ronde 2
donc kit carreau contre gauche
bah écoute pour l'instant
il fait cavalier 5 et il veut jouer F4
ensuite clairement et attaquer texte
comme il dit des cartouches tout à fait
il est là
pour enfin voilà un petit peu cette
attaque de minorité et affaiblir les
pions
c'est vrai que oui c'est pratique de
jouer des bits tous les jours
bah je me mets en route c'est sûr
c'est sûr
parce qu'en fait il joue pas des joueurs
il essaie de jouer des joueurs forts à
part quand il joue contre Algérie
donc il va jouer Alger Hello
mais sinon il joue quand même des
joueurs forts et donc il garde la main
il a perdu contre girlo elle dit allô a
battu le Grand Dakar incroyable
mais c'était quoi cette un tournoi
c'était
non je crois qu'il s'est fait tu sais
parfois il a du mal à trouver des
joueurs
un peu moins bien classés en tout cas
je crois qu'elle gère l'eau il se
débrouille bien
j'ai cru voir qu'il avait eu des
problèmes
je l'avais vu sur facebook quelque chose
ok bon je crois bien faudra leur
demander mais chat
c'est le biwan maintenant je suis pas
encore remis bientôt j'espère
on n'est pas loin
[Musique]
juste un truc qui prend comme un
divertissement voilà il s'amuse un petit
peu
pourquoi pas et puis il a des résultats
très corrects il fait souvent des prix
60e à l'EPT de Monte-Carlo mais c'est
pas mal 60e elle a pété de Monte-Carlo
il y a du challenge au poker mais ouais
il est quand même il a l'air doué il est
doué cet homme là
on joue quoi là sur dame aussi c'est 5
c'est génial on va faire
il est dans son élément là
est-ce que tu veux quoi c'est un petit
tour rapide
[Musique]
parce que si aloha elle perd pas contre
un divan
[Musique]
il peut quand même faire des trucs
bizarres parfois et d'ailleurs elle a
l'air très bien
pour le coup
donc ok
les pièces
c'est ce que j'ai comme combine ici sur
cahier des deux je peux le faire par
exemple
soit et prend des quatre
temps mais peut-être tu as raison
peut-être qu'elle a 4 mois
donc en fait tu peux donner la pièce en
échange de manger le fou etc après faut
quand même faire gaffe à la dame mais
bon j'attaque toujours cavalier donc
j'ai le temps un peu de sortir et j'ai
pensé le même thème ici en prend mais je
mange là jusqu'à la perte de fou mais je
pensais aussi un jeu fouf-5 là pour te
donner et manger des œufs et en même
temps ça peut venir sur les cases là
donc bon
[Musique]
après qu'elle prend puis on prend il
faut prendre quatre ça me dit quelque
chose
cavalier prend tu reprends des quatre il
faut prendre des quatre
tours
ok il faut G7
[Musique]
et si tu recules je fais fou avant un
truc comme ça
si tu te mets dans la diagonale
prend pour faire la fourchette comme ça
sauf que non je
j'hallucine un petit peu donc avaler ces
trois
a été joué ouais non mais tu as pas
envie de donner Focas noir en fait et
même c'est bien ce que tu as ce que tu
as ce que tu as montré mais même je
pense que 5 presque sans réfléchir enfin
juste tu sens que tu as la case des
quatre
et sur Foot G7 c'est plus que c'est le
coup mais j'ai déjà regardé ce truc là
après à l'époque donné par même avril
dans son bouquin ok quand il avait fait
un des quatre là avec G3 et donc là faut
quelque chose comme ça
la fois il me semble alors
c'est peut-être ma mémoire qui a pas
fait de progrès c'est aussi très très
possible non mais très bien aussi
contre
[Musique]
vous
et c'est une partie un petit peu un
chose depuis le début c'est quoi
ah oui toujours
un peu bizarre
c'est l'acrobate
il aime bien les positions et envie de
jouer c'est hypertendu alors B4 bien sûr
il fait sans lever du clouage maintenant
qu'il y a plus de cloises et ben il y a
un peu tout en prise quoi donc quelqu'un
va les prendre
puis on prend
C5 donc il faut ouvrir sauf quasiment il
est hyper offensive
[Rires]
en espagnol
c'est vraiment pas terrible je sais
commander à manger finalement ça sert
quand même
tous les jours
l'équipe indienne qui vient de
s'incliner
je sais pas ouais le chef tu me tu me
saoules attention en 600 secondes
bientôt tu me dis ou tu fais tu fais pas
de devinettes c'est pas toi qui fait de
devinette
mais le roi blanc est quand même plus
facilement
plus facilement à l'abri avec le tiroc
alors que le roi noir il est vraiment
ensemble quoi j'ai dû dépendre aussi du
drama 4 j'ai eu d'un projet 4 il y a
aussi tout repensé 3 il y a plein plein
de menaces et seulement trois minutes à
la pendule c'est hyper chaud tu vois
qu'en plus il est tranquille chez lui
franchement
[Musique]
il est quand même
alors comment est-ce qu'on joue ici à
tomber trois mais la logique tour B3 ça
empêchera plus tard dans ma cadre donc
je pourrai plus passer à cause de à
cause de la tour ici tour à deux elle a
aussi assez logique dans la 4 aussi la
maquette il y a quand même toujours fou
des sets qui va arriver donc pas
forcément d'échanger les dames c'est une
position de d'attaque donc c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu dommage
trop compliqué c'est trop chaud je
pensais me maquiller avec ces quatre
mais en fait non
[Musique]
tellement opposé c'est un truc de ouf
mais en fait moi je vois cette position
je vois que lui il a du mal à
non non rien mais en fait moi j'aime pas
non mais non mais ça me fait marrant ça
me fait marrer ton style
qui veut jouer cet avantage jusqu'au
bout
alors que moi je veux mater même quand
je suis mal ce qui se passe
le damacat tout prend cavaler prendre un
décès de prise en E65
puis on prend aussi mais bon ça doit
être nul
ok je crois que je prends du rouge
je préférerais largement la jouer avec
les Blancs celle-là ça c'est clair et
net mais il y a pas eu tout ça
appartient
madame
c'est le seul coup pour que la tour
puisse défendre la fuite et qui a plus
de la fuite je crois qu'il y a rien en
fait du coup
en prise et puis si je fais ça ça il y a
au pire demain ouais c'est quand même
très compliqué
[Musique]
quand un poisson dans l'eau dans un
autre truc
[Musique]
des petites des petites menaces
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup les blancs ici
franchement
je pense que les blancs vont gagner
tu es d'accord
c'est un jouable je pense que la
position
[Musique]
qui calme tout le monde
coucou
[Musique]
en pratique pas si simple il y a
toujours du jeu en fait pour les blancs
parce que
c'est chaud
quand même on voit que c'est pas c'est
pas simple hein c'est pas chose c'est
ultra ultra compliqué bien sûr nous on
joue avec la jauge et puis on n'a pas
beaucoup de profondeur enfin on bouge
les pièces quoi non c'est clair
à chaque coup
et la pollution elle est un calculable
enfin on va dire que ça va
ah oui mais humainement
avec peu de temps la pendule même pour
un très très bon joueur même pour 45
c'est dur
bien sûr faire avec les Noirs
les positions et les maires
mais ça tu donnes ça tu penses que les
Noirs à n'importe qui
après t'allais noir tu as deux pions de
plus les chances de gagner ou tomber 4
[Musique]
qui devient un petit peu faible
peut-être potentiellement
il faut trouver des couleurs
[Musique]
peut-être tourner
sur ce plan-là qu'un jour peut-être que
je vais jouer à 4h5 enfin ça marche pas
mais bon tu avais pas envie de ça
qui vient attaquer la dame je suis
presque choqué matin ça je suis choqué
[Musique]
non il y a le cavalier C3 mais Damien
tu es obligé de prendre je pense
après
mais ils sont ils sont forts
[Musique]
donc l'option c'est c'est un pion qui
est doublé mais bon j'ai la paire de fou
quand même faut oublier donc sur le long
terme j'ai toujours un petit avantage
quand même avec les noirs
donc c'est la partie une dame prend un 4
dans un prochain 4 donc bien évidemment
il veut garder les pièces c'est
compréhensible avec les Blancs le roi
noir est un peu faible il a un peu moins
il a pas trop intérêt à
échanger quoi
j'en sais rien
j'activé la dernière pièce et finalement
mon roi en G7 il est pas si mal au final
le roi qui vous est très peur qui était
un courant d'air il est pas si mal 18
secondes par contre il faut qu'il se
dépêche
pour l'instant il y a pas le donner sans
fous
9 secondes par contre contre une minute
c'est un diable hein
gagner leur partie les attaquants
et mon champion vory d'Off il peut plier
le match il peut il peut terminer le
match s'il gagne là bon
donc victoire impérative la déréglée
j'y crois pas une seule seconde pour
retourner
ouais ça se gâte un petit peu pour pour
une boisson qui est tellement dur en
pratique
et en plus contre contre l'Asie qui a
pas de lâché et puis en plus il y a il y
a quand même l'avantage de temps aussi
c'est très dur là il y a plein de
tactiques qui vont arriver peut-être
même jusqu'à 4 ramener des pièces
ok répétition non pas prendre
garantie parole de texte
mais même même si vos Reader faire cette
partie franchement attention non je vous
souhaite
qui est mieux
en tout cas
je t'ai dit qu'il était bon
tu m'écoutes pas tu me dis les Indiens
les Indiens moi je te dis rideau
1586 c'est pas beaucoup
j'ai vu jouer
je me suis dit j'ai pas envie de jouer
Dame des deux
ça avec si peu de temps
et puis c'est bien il y a deux flèches
devant toute façon il panique un peu
quand même il revient
en avant en arrière
et là c'est pas terrible ce qui fait la
dernière coupe
ça panique
il revient quand même
c'est possible
regardez moi ça que c'est que c'est dur
fout des deux et oui que c'est dur ce
jeu le carrier dominé en deux que c'est
dur ce jeu
F5 échec ouais obligé qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ouais
25 fois avec n'importe quelle couleur
de de vouloir gagner avec les Noirs vu
que
je mange non
[Musique]
du coup
danse dans ce match
normalement il devrait gagner ouais
faut dominer juste il veut faire bref
le roi de la petite combine
avec son malin ah ouais ça peut pas
l'enlever
incroyable trois un un
non non
c'est en plus elle joue bien aloha
Thomas il est quasiment d'aide en fait
mais les Gotham Knight c'est vrai que on
avait dit je crois qu'ils ont gagné
combien deux ou trois matchs déjà je ne
sais plus avant le quatrième 7
Nick avant là ils mettent vos rideaux je
savais pas que c'est vos rideaux ils
mettent les deux attaquants ça c'est
clair moi fais le CF et après il tourne
mais alors vos rideau comme remplaçant
dis non
et elle a l'air de jouer pas mal notre
ami
26 plus quoi
alors je vais mettre les cames et je
vais
vous dire un apparemment en même temps
que je l'aimais on va avoir dans cette
33 on va avoir adiban avec les Blancs
contre Nakamura
qui va venir avec les Noirs
c'est vraiment le le
[Musique]
meilleur joueur de son équipe et même
d'ailleurs du monde quasiment
donc on a ça première table on a
irigazie blanc qui vient de perdre
sa partie
irrigazie il a les blancs c'est bien
placé contre fedoceïev
donc fais dos c'est la compagnon de
de Naka spécialiste aussi de parties des
parties Blitz sur Internet toujours très
dangereux
genre très offensif vraiment
tac
ensuite on va avoir vous qui
il est où
il va avoir les blancs
il va avoir les blancs face à
un Rica c'est ça
va être chaud et n'oubliez pas demain
pendant que Stéphane fait ses réglages
demain on est là 15h30 mais je crois 3e
place 18h 30 finale de cette ligue qui
aurait été passionnante de bout en bout
et on aura le dénouement
avec malheureusement on avait une équipe
française qui a fait un bon parcours
parcours tout à fait
honorable et bon même mais ouais hier
mauvais match un petit peu un peu en
dessous pas de Maxime parce que quand je
tourne donc pas de chance dommage qu'il
y a pas eu Maxime évidemment ça aurait
pu changer beaucoup de choses
et voilà ça c'est je vois pas grand
chose mais c'est comme ça ça s'est
arrêté hier en quart de finale quart de
finale qui est quand même bah l'équipe
de vanus carsel elle a pas fait quart de
finale tu vois donc c'est quand même un
bon résultat
donc bah si c'est demi un demi en plus
tu avais dit que c'était ça allait être
une victoire écrasante pour l'instant
excuse-moi
pour l'instant c'est juste ça se passe
comme je l'ai dit
ils sont encore derrière quoi
en fait il faut mettre deux points sur
huit parties
en plus parce que je veux dire ah oui
non il faut mettre il faut mettre deux
points
sur huit parties
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
ouais non c'est
ils vont pas commencer
façon donc
les blancs contre Henri Ivan peut se
placer n'importe quoi et il est
probable de la fort probable que qu'il
n'y ait pas de quatrième set dans ce
match de la Process League donc les
joueurs qui sont un petit peu habitués à
ça dans ce type là c'est vraiment il y a
eu je crois qu'il y a eu quasiment que
peut-être que cette équipe là ou même
une autre peut-être qui ont réussi à
gagner en 3 7
trois matchs gagnés c'était bon on était
qualifiés donc en fait ils ont beaucoup
moins de matchs joués et quasiment tout
leur match ils gagnent entre 7
ça monte quand même certaines
dominations quoi dans la compétition
ouais
les favoris bon là évidemment c'est
facile parce que du coup il y a 6 et
demi à nuit mais ils sont favoris pour
demain aussi mais les Chinois aussi
impressionnant quand même
les Chinois
il y a une constance dans ces Chinois
les Chinois qu'ils ont je
vais peut-être des bêtises peut-être tu
peux me corriger mais je les ai jamais
vu être mené en fait dans leur match ils
sont toujours gagné
assez assez tranquille quand même
je sais pas le souvenir de d'avoir vu
être mené dans un match
un peu une surprise on savait pas trop
bah en fait on savait pas trop ce que ce
qui valait ces Indiens enfin c'est
chinois tu vois un maître international
à 2500 hello bon
mais en fait
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ils sont tous 2005 mais
hyper constant en fait ils font tous des
surprises tout le temps quoi
il est bien aidé par
ses poursuivants qui font qui font le
taf joint jaune qui fait un gros taf
aussi ouais franchement c'est des belles
équipes
est-ce qu'il y a une pause
normalement non bah si tu veux en faire
une on peut en faire une petite courte
tu me laisses 2 minutes
on revient pour le dernier set a priori
bac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour le match vient
de commencer à l'instant troisième ronde
de ce match six et demi 1 et demi pour
pour les Gotham Knights amenés par
Nakamura donc là on voit habiban contre
Nakamura comme tu l'avais dit hein
les Indiens largement favoris j'ajoute
en plus j'ai même pas besoin d'en
rajouter c'est pas vrai mais en donnant
les Indiens favoris quand même
le pif là le pif si vous avez une grille
de l'auto en remplir appelé Stéphane et
puis voilà c'est bon en fait mais mes
pronos était mauvais parce que tu sais
je disais qu'ils avaient quatre points 4
points quasiment gratuit à cause de la
féminine de de
Gotham que je sous-estimais un petit peu
j'avoue mais en fait il faut savoir que
à chaque fois il joue trois parties quoi
on a une certitude pour cette partie là
quand on regarde entre adivan il va tout
envoyer mais alors ça va être ça va être
quelque chose je pense
ouais bah oui même la partie la partie
réghasief aussi je vais la voir aussi
franchement c'est passé deux parties oui
tu laisses faire [__] F3
est-ce que c'est bien est-ce que c'est
pas bien j'en sais rien moi mais il l'a
fait à la vitesse de l'éclair ah il
rigole pas
il rigole pas notre ami a dit bah
est-ce qu'on fait vous pourrez trop ou
pas mais si les blancs
après c'est pas gagnant mais voilà il a
pas fait mais quand même il y a un
avantage blanc assez indiscutable je
trouve
d'ailleurs je vois je l'avais pas vu ce
petit
annonce du de la recherche du monteur
vidéo pour tscom alors si dans le chat
il y a des gens qui qui
leur boulot de monter les vidéos et qui
sont en tout cas peut-être bon là-dedans
n'hésitez pas à envoyer votre CV à
cheesecoms
si vous êtes sur le stream
donc n'hésitez pas ouais travailler dans
les déchets comme rendez-vous d'échec en
vrai c'est un boulot si c'est en tout
cas c'est c'est un bon passe-temps que
vous avez ou en tout cas c'est c'est
votre boulot de monter un peu des vidéos
bah si en plus vous aimez les chèques
franchement
et ouais ça recruteur c'est pas du
bluffant les chaînes ou Stéphane n'est
pas là ça recrute
ok donc il mange jamais froid en fait il
laisse hein et réfléchi mais c'est une
grosse décision
le fou B2
il croise les doigts
donc il veut jouer BF5 peut-être un truc
comme ça où il veut juste faire il veut
sécuriser la caisse du cavalier en C6
qui sera une très très belle case il a
raison intéressant
qui touche pas
qui peut être faible non mais où est-ce
que tu es le blanc c'est ça en fait le
truc
j'ai un d'abord et puis bon ensuite
je peux pas trop trop enfin je voulais
faire ça en fait mais je veux leur faire
[__] d'un E3 un truc
et c'est pas très agréable j'ai 6
et en fait c'est vrai que maintenant
qu'on a réussi à jouer des cinq et ben
ce fou en B2 pour l'instant et pas si
bon que ça mais après bon peut-être le
fou il pourra se recycler sur la case
noire là-bas de noter que les noirs et
ben non pas trop de casse moi
parce qu'avant que le fou il arrive
juste là pour l'instant
dans l'idée les Noirs ont fait ça pour
essayer de jouer contre le fou B2 aussi
merci il se fait complètement raser le
Power
cette position déjà c'est marrant Naka
qui réfléchit trois minutes sur un coup
et maintenant qu'il va tout tempo quoi
par rapport à son plan Tyler un instant
il a un instant Naka c'est ouf quand
même
si je prends là tu vas manger du pur en
dés et le fou va se retrouver
c'est interdit par la loi
B5 pour préparer gentiment à 5 mais ça
doit être un peu lent
parce que je suis obligé de jouer encore
un coup de tourner vite pour protéger
mon pion B
ça fait
et
impossible ou trop bien ouais
j'ai beaucoup de chance
du vis-à-vis d'un éventuel quoi c'est ça
ouais
regardez
[Musique]
les caméras
ok mais blanc j'aime bien les blancs là
paire de fou
sympa pour les blancs honnêtement
ok
ça serait bien quand même qu'on est un
quatrième set pour le suspense
bon ben c'est cuit hein mais
faudra un gros score des Indiens
clairement au moins trois au minimum
au grand minimum 3 il y a encore 3 ça
serait dur
c'est pas fait pour les enfants va
arriver
et j'habite
c'est vrai que je vais essayer en plus
c'est un joueur qui normal allemand mais
la pression aussi au temps ouais c'est
un petit peu emmené
au play in CF il a il a pris j'étais
même bien longtemps ça m'a surpris
finalement ça a fait nul mais il était
tu vois il a pris son temps c'était un
peu de surprise donc ça dépend des
parties je pense que globalement je suis
comme toi je pense que c'est plutôt un
joueur qui joue vite mais si considère
que
il y a vraiment des
de quoi
oui
le fait quoi c'est pas comme ça c'est un
genre professionnel
[Musique]
c'est un avantage parce que c'est un
défaut des fois
des fois ça te porte à peu près jeudi
alors on l'a vu dans le match
malheureusement pour enfin
malheureusement c'est pas spécialement
pour les peaux mais pour des peaux ça
lui a joué des tours des gros tours même
là à se calmer à réfléchir
correctement sur les moments critiques
ok la partie de Naka est quand même plus
marrante non
défense
je remets les caméras il a claqué H5 je
remonte un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
il y a eu roi H8
B5 qui est fermé pour jouer à 5 et
ouvrir tous les dames
et à tourger un et là il a bouffé
là-haut pour ramener les pièces et il
veut faire ça et ça qui a l'air quand
même intéressant H6 a été joué surtout
prochain G7 et voilà tout de case
mais les pâtes à câble et il joue F4 F4
[Musique]
parce que F4 ok certes alors
il y a toujours
pas ça c'est pas ça
c'est un truc en plus
pipeau pour les jouer cavaliers
et là je te fais un coup de tour à deux
pour te faire peur
ah non je te fais pas peur j'ai ma tour
en prise
[Musique]
si jamais ça pouvait se jouer ici il y a
un tour Eiffel qui est très joli qui
cloue la dame
donc il y a quand même des trucs mais
bon
défense
c'est elle sinon comment il est fort
c'est quand même fait embrouiller ok ok
alors peut-être
c'est que je menace presque comment je
fais
prise
tout le temps
qu'elle va les prendre cet échec là
je crois qu'il veut venir en D2 avec le
froid qui veut être le fou par là il
empêche à 5 aussi ah c'est malin sans
coup
et que les résultats sont favorables
pour les Indiens ça peut ça peut un peu
un peu tourné je dis pas quand même je
vous rappelle que les mettre deux points
pour pour mettre fin à ce match ils ont
déjà
mais à mon avis elle va être gratiner
cette partie
pour l'instant mais je pense qu'il va
gagner
la Tour Eiffel il y a plein de coups
qu'on a quand même plutôt sympa je pense
qu'il va gagner tranquillement
[Musique]
en fait qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
4 échecs on signe la feuille on félicite
son adversaire
victoire de vos rideau
qui se qui se craque les mains comme ça
on l'a vu
il sait qu'il a gagné il sait que c'est
fini
aussi
pour que tout gagne ici
encaisse le plus de matériel
et complètement fini
pour la casser dommage
juste c'est une très bonne chose mais là
c'est juste c'est la marche un tout
petit peu trop haute pour vraiment faire
plus de poids donc il fait 330
est-ce qu'on repart tu veux aller sur ma
carte c'est chaud chaud
et c'est hyper chaud je pense qu'on a
qu'à perdre hein
il est très très bon en défense il y a
beaucoup l'impression d'être faitouter
et il est hyper opportuniste donc il
faut l'achever encore
c'est un joueur que tu l'as battes
plusieurs fois pour gagner
clairement il est pas content mais
il sait que c'est pas terminé
il faut il faut terminer il faut
terminer
vois pas le coup en tout cas
ça marche ou pas
trop notre couple après il y a toujours
ok
ça peut très très vite se retourner là
je défends et à Tours je serai pas
optimiste avec les Blancs c'est tout
enfermé
qu'est-ce qu'on joue après sur sur ça
tu vois j'ai un pion passé aussi et sans
longtemps c'est con qui sont un peu
faibles même la finale la question avec
la paire de fou
qui était de moi même la finale a l'air
intéressante pour le moment
ouais genre F6 si je même si je pour
illustrer illustrer pardon ton propos
peut-être rêve si je non les Noirs
jouets si je prends ça me prend on
reprend
[Musique]
parce que le purge si c'est en prise
donc je peux faire faux 3 et ramener la
tour vers F5 et comme tu le dis la paire
de fou avec les pions qui qui poussent
comme ça
il va être d'accord pour l'annuaire
vu le score du match je me dis qu'il dit
deux pièces
et mes deux fois positionnés
et j'étais à plus 10
et je me suis pris maintenant
j'ai fait une grosse grosse partie
je trouve que c'est pas le plus dur
d'avoir une bonne position contre
d'accord au final non mais en fait
il se défend tellement bien ouais c'est
un truc de ouf en fait il te rend fou en
fait il te rend fou parce que plein de
fois c'est vrai que plein de fois il
joue vite le système bizarre ils veulent
juste tu vois mais derrière il y a tout
le temps
il se défend mais juste il trouve des
ressources que tu aurais même pas
imaginer
et
c'est pas quoi faire là il tourne en
rond
une minute 23 pour pour les blancs
contre une minute 50
c'est chaud chaud
je vais regarder un peu ce qui se passe
à côté la loi qui
[Musique]
qui a la complètement foutu la loi qui
est complètement perdante ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les Indiens
[Musique]
1 2 3 4 et puis en plus pour fait donc
est passé à travers
faut dire ce qui est
les périodes
et ses dossiers ils ont 3003
et demi incroyable
en fait
le résultat enfin ils ont tous zéro
quasiment quoi c'est un truc de fou quoi
[Rires]
j'ai annoncé ouais mais je pensais pas
qu'il allait avoir 8 et demi et demi je
vais quand même être honnête je pensais
je voyais une belle vie
facile mais à ce point là c'est plus
facile là c'est un massacre il y a pas
d'autres mots
[Musique]
c'est un truc pour les Indiens enfin tu
vois
[Musique]
ça fait quand même une fois
il connaît le score donc en fait tu
crois non mais le score il savait qu'ils
étaient deux points avant avant le match
de 9-2 il reste une partie aloha allons
voir aloha allez on va la voir aloha
aloha ouais elle va perdre elle joue
contre gauche
[Musique]
ils ont fait trois points
magazine il était pas en forme
aujourd'hui mais sinon c'est un
excellent joueur magazique capable de
franchement il aurait pu faire 100 %
dans ce match comme faire zéro quoi
petite mauvaise période quand même pour
erghezy avec quelques tournois
c'est mal passé malmeeu là c'est pas
très bien passé
un peu on n'est pas habitué à aller voir
ces Indiens perdre des points
[Musique]
en fait elle a tenté le petit piège bon
bah du du gars qui va qui va perdre
enfin qui abandonne pour faire mais
maintenant il y a eu dommage de
intermédiaire qui fait échec qui
forceront les fins et du coup je te
reprends F3 qui fait mat donc 9 3
9 3
c'était un peu triste pour les années
quand même parce que là le match
c'est
sens unique Gotham gros favori pour
demain évidemment bah oui
en 3.7 ça a l'air complètement
comme tu l'as dit ils ont quand même ce
gros point faible c'est vrai que
elle a fait un demi sur trois
est-ce qu'on aurait pu faire quelque
chose qu'on travaille quand on sait pas
et il suffit que les joueurs qui un
joueur de 3 qui soit pas forcément en
forme et ça peut mal se passer ouais
mais là ils ont l'air
ils ont fait le match
[Musique]
tu vois demain contre les Chinois ben
écoute elle a fini la moitié 50 demain
elle peut très bien accrocher
accrocher un chinois
donc
ok ok
demain je parierai pas
[Rires]
aussi vas-y
c'est combien pour partir au Top 16
parce que faire
faut toujours essayer de se refaire
sinon tu vas faire sinon donc demain
c'est quoi demain c'est 15h30 la
troisième place donc ça va être l'équipe
des Indiens contre l'autre équipe
indienne doit faire c'est un match 100%
indien pour la troisième place et la
finale on aura
Nakamura donc l'emblème meilleur
streamer au monde un des meilleurs
joueurs de Blitz au monde aussi des
Gotham Knights qui va jouer contre les
Chinois qui sont depuis les conditions
complètement impressionnant
donc avoir un peu ce qui se passe et
donc demain ce match là il sera à 18h je
crois Laurent tout à fait c'est 15h30 le
premier match suivi 18h30 on a l'antenne
du début à la fin donc on sera là donc
je sais c'est marrant tu as pas appris
les
leçons de voir tes coups de pack Kevin
ça me rassure parce que j'ai dit tout à
fait mais j'étais pas sûr à 100%, je
vais vérifier ça tout de suite
attends je vais vérifier
pareil ouais 15h30 18h
à 18h mais petite finale sympa quand
même bah
ça va être un praguer les Gazi toujours
sympa un petit derby
les nouveaux joueurs du circuit et donc
voilà merci à tous d'avoir suivi le
stream merci merci à toi Laurent de
m'avoir accompagné et donc demain demain
même heure même programme donc demain je
me connecterai direct avec le code
cheeseccom alors là j'ai vu je vous ai
dit
c'est la faute de cheesecom là pour le
coup il pensait qu'il m'avait mis les
droits mais j'ai pas les droits
on peut les avoir pour pas cher
quand je l'ai dit je me suis dit ah il
va me faire la f je sais que c'est ton
habitude
et d'ailleurs en parlant de blague j'ai
un petit message sur le chat yes Mama
qui te non non non non non je t'interdis
ça merci à tous à demain
on va être avis on a passé une
excellente journée on va surtout pas la
gâcher par ce truc là ne t'inquiète pas
il y a ce moment ça arrive ça sera un
jeudi
on sait pas quand je dis merci à tous et
bonne soirée à tous à demain 15h30 passe
une excellente soirée à bientôt et bonne
soirée à toi Laurent